SEATS WILL BE.
GETTING STARTED IN JUST A SECOND
[inaudible]
I'VE.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE WELCOME TO
THE MARCH THIRTEENTH --
TWO FOR TWENTY NINETEEN MEETING
GOV ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER.
THREE WE'RE GOING --
TO SKIP OVER A THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR FOR A MOMENT SINCE WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM AND WE WILL
BE VOTING ON THAT BUT AS SOON AS
WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
WE WILL WE WILL MOVE BACK TO
THAT WE'VE HAD A REQUEST TO TAKE
ISSUES EIGHT AND NINE SEPARATELY
AND AND SO WE'LL DO THAT IN DUE
COURSE.
UNDER ITEMS TO BE HEARD I'M
GOING TO OUR FOR THE SAKE OF
CONVENIENCE OF FOR SOME OF THE
FOLKS WHO ARE HRE --
DO A SLIGHT REORDERING OF THE OF
THE AGENDA WILL TAKE ISSUE TOWN
FIRST.
AND THEN MOVE BACK TO ISSUE
NUMBER.
ONE SO --
DOES IF YOU WERE HERE ON ISSUE.
TEN IF YOU STEP FORWARD THAT BE
GREAT.
THE MORNING MORNING.
THANK YOU SIR BLOOM AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON THREE SIDES
SO --
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS I'M HERE WITH DANIEL
SUBPAR.
DEPUTY FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY --
I'M SPEAKS TO ISSUE NUMBER --
TEN AS YOU.
CAN SEE FROM THE AT CHEN A NINE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS HAS
BEEN --
APPROPRIATED BY THE OR REQUESTED
BY THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO FUND
THE WORKING DRYING PHASE FOR OUR
FOR TUNA GREEN WOULD --
LAS PENAS AND ARE YOU CAR
RESIDENTIAL CENTERS AND WE
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF THE OF
MEMBERS AND AND HER TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
ABOUT THIS OUR PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU YOU A LITTLE BIT
FASTER THAN I THOUGHT YOU MIGHT.
SUSAN DEAD INSIDE IRAQ
INSTRUCTORS THE KEEPER MEN'S
SHAMA WITH LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE DON'T RAISE ANY ISSUES
WITH THIS.
AND SAID FROM THE FINANCE.
CRYSTAL VENDRAMIN OF FINANCE --
NO SHE'S ALL RIGHT --
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING NONE WE DO HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION TO APPROVE
DIRECTOR SITEL AND AS SOON AS WE
HAVE A QUORUM WE'LL SEE IF WE
CAN'T GET A VOTE ON THAT.
THANK YOU.
SAID THAT WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
ISSUE NUMBER ONE WHICH INVOLVES%
A NUMBER OF DEPARTMENTS IT'S
QUITE A OF LONG AGENDA ITEM HI
AND TO SCHOOL.
WORK OUR WAY THROUGH THAT.
CHIEF PORTER YOU'RE GONNA BE
LEADING US OFF ON THE SERVER.
DO I HAVE THAT RIGHT.
YES AND DID YOU WANT A LITTLE OF
BACKGROUND YES YEAR PLEASE.
READ GERMAN A GERMAN BLOOM --
BUT JUST TO KIND OF SET THE
STAGE -- FOR
FOR HOW WE'VE GOTTEN --
TO THESE PROPOSALS.
THAT ARE IN FRONT OF YOU TODAY --
AND AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
WE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS YOU
ALL KNOW IS BETTER WITH IT WAS
THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRE --
YOU'RE JUST GETTING STARTED SO
RATHER THAN INTERRUPT YOU AT A
LESS OPPORTUNE MOMENT WHEN IT WE
TAKE ROLE IN THE STEPS QUORUM
SINCE SOMEBODY MIGHT HAVE TO
LEAVE IT WE NEVER KNOW WHEN
SOMEBODY MIGHT HAVE TO LEAVE
[inaudible]
BLOOM.
FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN PATTERSON RADIUS.
REVERSE.
AT CHIEF OF FEELING DAHLE JUST
WILL TAKE A COUPLE OF QUICK
VOTES HERE --
ON THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR IF I
CAN -- CALL
US -- OUR
TENSION TO THAT --
IN ON ISSUES ONE THROUGH.
SEVEN I GET THAT RIGHT
[inaudible]
IS.
RIGHT TO VOTE BLOOM I FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN PATTERSON RADIUS
[inaudible]
REVERSE.
AND I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
ISSUES EIGHT AND NINE PLEASE
[inaudible]
I CLONE [inaudible]
HI FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN PATTERSON RAY YES
[inaudible]
REVERSE.
WE HAVE ON ISSUE --
TEN WHICH WE TOOK OUT OF ORDER.
FOR FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO JUST
ARRIVED --
ON ISSUE TEN WE HAVE A TO
APPROVE IS THERE A MOTION.
SEC.
THANK YOU.
BLOOM AYE FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN PATTERSON RADIUS
[inaudible]
YES.
THANK YOU I'M SORRY TO FOR THE
INTERRUPTION --
PLEASE PROCEED.
NOT A PROBLEM CHAIRMAN.
SO. TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BEING
THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE.
AND DEADLY AND DAMAGING SEASON
THAT WE'VE HAD AND IT'S REALLY
WAS A FIRE YEAR AS WE'VE BEEN
SEEING -- IN
THE IN THE RECENT HISTORY --
I'M JUST GOING TO REMIND YOU OF
THE FOR KIND OF CAPSTONE OR
CORNERSTONE FIRES THAT OCCURRED
LAST YEAR THE MEDICS MENDOCINO
COMPLEX.
NOW THE LARGEST FIRE IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
THE CAR --
WHICH BURNED OR XIN OF OF
READING AND THE SURROUNDING
AREAS.
AND THE AND THEY HAD A A EXTREME
WEATHER EVENT --
INDIA -- FOR
CATEGORY TORNADO LIKE A FIRE
WORLD --
SOMETHING WE HAD NOT SEEN BEFORE.
OTHER WILL SEE FIRE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BURNS --
INTO MALIBU RIGHT TO THE BEACH
BURNED. TEN MILES OF COASTLINE
RIGHT DOWN TO THE SAND IN SOME
CASES.
AND THEN OF COURSE THE CAMP FIRE
WHICH WAS --
THE RIDGE THAT INCLUDES A
PARADISE --
CON CAO MAHALIA AND OTHER
COMMUNITIES AND AND THE REASON
I'M BRINGING THIS BACK TO
ATTENTION IS THESE THOUGH THEY
ARE THE MOST NOTABLE THEY'RE NOT
THE ONLY FIRES THAT HAPPENED
LAST YEAR AND LAST YEAR WAS. ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION ACRES WORTH
OF OF WILDFIRE THE REALLY
DEVASTATED PARTS OF CALIFORNIA.
AND SOME OF THE NOTABLE THING --
WE HAVE AN ARE ATTRIBUTING TO
CUT CLIMATE CHANGE RELATED TO
THIS -- IS
WELL CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE THE
EFFECTS OF THE DROUGHT THAT --
A IS NOT OVER FOR THE VEGETATION
THE VEGETATION IS STILL --
DEAD OR OR STRESSED AND WILL NOT
COME BACK IN OVERNIGHT FROM
THESE RAINS WE'VE BEEN HAVING --
THIS WINTER --
WE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE DROUGHT
LIKE CONDITIONS IN THE FUELS --
IT TAKES A VERY LONG TIME FOR
LARGE FUELS TO TAKE ON MORE EACH
JUROR AND REDUCE THE THE THREAT
OF THEM BURNING --
AND DOES IT THIS IS THE STAGE
THAT -- WE
BRING THESE PROPOSALS TO YOU
UNDER [inaudible]
THE IN PARTICULAR --
ON THE CAMP INCIDENT THE FIRE
STARTED IN AN AREA WHERE A
RECENT FIRE HAD BURNED AND THERE
WERE HAVE YOU EVERY FUELS IT
BURNED TO THE RICH --
WIND CONDITIONS DRY WIND
CONDITIONS THAT WERE HAPPENING.
AT A POINT IN THE YEAR WHERE WE
USUALLY HAVE AT TWO TO FOUR
INCHES OF RAIN IN THE AREA.
WHICH WOULD HAVE STARTED TO TO
TO GREEN UP AND AND VOICE IN THE
FUELS THE SAME TIME THAT THAT
WIND WAS BLOWING OVERNIGHT.
NEEDLES WERE FALLING OUT OF THE
PINE TREES TYPICAL ANNUAL EVENT.
SO NO MATTER HOW MUCH THE
NEIGHBORHOODS OF OF PARADISE
WOULD HAVE RAKED OR MOVE REMOVED
THE THE FUEL STRUCTURES IT ALL
CAME BACK OVERNIGHT.
AND THE EMBERS FROM THESE HEAVY
FUELS THAT WERE STILL VERY BONE
DRY -- ON
THAT ON THAT PREVIOUS FIRE
LANDSCAPE.
SHOWERED INTO PARADISE --
JUST HOURS SHORT HOURS AFTER --
IGNITION OF THE FIRE --
PUTTING THE FIRE IN PARADISE
FROM A DISTANCE THAT NORMALLY
WOULD HAVE TAKEN SIX TO EIGHT
HOURS.
SO IT MOVED TO FIRE VERY QUICKLY
INTO TOWN THAT NEEDLE CAST
ALLOWED FOR THE FIRE TO SPREAD
IN TOWN VERY QUICKLY.
AND THEN THE REST OF THE STORY
YOU'VE HEARD AND YOU KNOW BUT
THESE ARE THESE ARE SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT ARE.
THAT HAVE A REALLY COME OUT IN
THE IN THE BROADER --
PUBLIC STORY AND I I THINK ARE
VERY IMPORTANT TO WHERE WORK --
TO WHERE WE'RE GOING.
SO.
WITH THAT BEING THE THE STAGE.
I THINK WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS --
LEAVE IT AT THAT FOR FOR YOU
CHAIR AND IF YOU CARE TO COME BY
TOPICS.
WHO I WOULD BE HAPPY TO TO BRING
THEM UP THROUGH FURTHER
[inaudible]
TESTIMONY.
GREAT HI ALISON YOU IT. NINETY
SAID WELCOME.
WHICH MEANS CO AUTHOR OF RIGHT.
I ALISON HERE AT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AT SAID MANY OF YOU KNOW
THAT AND SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
A COMPREHENSIVE WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND RECOVERY PACKAGE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO IMPLEMENT
THIS PACKAGE THIS INCLUDES TWO
HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR CAL FIRE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
CONSISTENT WITH THE PROVISIONS
OF SB NINE A ONE AS WELL AS TEN
MILLION --
TO IMPLEMENT OTHER REQUIREMENTS
OF THE LEGISLATION AND THEN
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR OTHER
DEPARTMENTS INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS OF
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
AND THAT PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S
OFFICE THEIR RESOURCES BOARD.
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
I WITH THAT EACH DEPARTMENT IS
PREPARED AT AND READY TO PRESENT
ON EACH OF THEIR INDIVIDUAL
REQUESTS.
THANK YOU WHO'S NEXT.
SO WILL TURN IT BACK OVER TO
CHIEF PORTER.
I DON'T KNOW THE ORDER GOING AND
SO.
WE'LL JUST LEAVE IT WILL KEEP IT
COMING.
ALL RIGHT --
RELATED --
TO THE THE AND AND THIS IS
RELATED TO ON ON YOUR IN YOUR
PACKET ON PAGE SIX THE THE
PROPOSALS THAT ARE THERE --
TO TO MEET THE NEEDS --
FOR THERE WERE OUTLINED IN --
THE SENATE BILL NINE A ONE
SENATE BILL TWELVE SIXTY
ASSEMBLY BILL --
FOR TWENTY FIVE EIGHTEEN THE
BILL --
TWENTY NINE ELEVEN CAL FIRE IS
REQUESTING --
TEN MILLION DOLLARS OF
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUNDS --
FOR TWENTY FOUR POSITIONS TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAMS --
THE THE FIRE PREVENTION PROGRAMS
AND EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS AND
OTHER ASPECTS OF THOSE BILLS --
AND I'M NOT GOING TO GO INTO
DETAIL ON EACH ONE BECAUSE YOU
HAVE THEM IN YOUR PACKET THE THE
THE RIGHT UP AYE I BELIEVE STAFF
DID A VERY GOOD JOB OF OF
WRITING UP THE THE SPECIFICS
THERE.
AND SO IN IN LIGHT OF A LONG
AGENDA AND SHORT TIME --
I WOULD LIKE --
TO JUST --
KICK THAT BACK --
TO YOU CHAIR IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME OR IF
YOU'D LIKE TO GET THROUGH THE
REST OF THE THE DIRECTORS AND
THEIR PIECES OF THIS PERSON --
I I DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS AT
THIS TIME.
IS ANYONE ELSE.
PLEASE PROCEED --
TO AFTER THOSE RATES.
AS A MEMBER OF THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE.
ON SB NINE A ONE I'M REALLY GLAD
TO THEY WERE ENTERING INTO THE
CRITICAL JUNCTURE WE'RE WE'RE
INSURING THAT THE MONEY THAT THE
ASSEMBLY.
PROPOSES --
TO TO BE USED IT TO HELP ADDRESS.
OF THIS CRISIS OF THE WILDFIRE
IS BEING USED.
I KNOW THAT --
THE ALLOCATION TO BE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
WHAT WHAT IS CAL FIRE DOING TO
ENSURE THAT RATHER THEN PICKING
THE BEST GRANT APPLICATION?
THAT WERE ACTUALLY LOOKING AT
THE AREAS OF NEED.
ESPECIALLY THE HIGH RISK AREAS
RATHER THAN JUST LOOKING AT IT.
GOOD GOOD APPLICATION.
THAT IS THAT IS A GREAT QUESTION
AND I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT RELATED TO THIS THIS
REQUESTED THIS WILL GIVE US THE
THE STAFF TO CONTINUE TO HELP
DOING THAT WE DO HAVE A A A A
GRANT --
PROGRAM THAT LOOKS AT THE THE
THE MERITSOF OF EACH PROJECT --
THE GEOGRAPHIC'S --
WE'RE WE'RE ALSO INCLUDING --
ITEMS FROM THE COMMUNITY WHAT --
PREVENTING COMMUNITY WHILE FIRE
PREVENTION AND MITIGATION REPORT
THAT JUST CAME OUT THE FORTY
FIVE DAY REPORT --
IT LOOKING AT SOCIO ECONOMIC HOW
MANY CHILDREN OR IN IN THE
COMMUNITY NUMBER OF VEHICLES PER --
PER HOUSEHOLD.
OR NO VEHICLES PER HOUSEHOLD
ELDERLY THOSE KIND OF THINGS
WHAT WE'VE WRAPPED ALL OF THOSE
INTO MAKING THESE.
THE THE ALLOCATION --
DESIGNED FOR THESE FUNDS AND
WE'RE BEING MUCH MORE TARGETED
TO WHERE THE VULNERABLE NEED IS --
AND IN AS WE ROLL THOSE FORWARD --
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE ABOUT SIXTY
MILLION THAT A DOLLARS THAT ARE --
GOING OUT TO FOREST'S --
FORCED HEALTH TYPE PROJECT WORK.
AND AND THEN FIRE PREVENTION IS
THE BALANCE.
IT VERY SPECIFICALLY ON THE THE
FOREST HEALTH AND FIRE
PREVENTION.
IS THERE ALL OF WORKING ON THE
PRODUCTION FOR THE NEXT THREE TO
FIVE YEARS ON WHAT IT IS WE NEED
TO DO -- TO
MAKE SURE WE GET TO THAT POINT.
YES IT'S ALL ABOUT IT'S IT'S ALL
PART OF A SYSTEMATIC APPROACH TO
LOOKING AT AND WHEN I SAY FIRE
PREVENTION THOSE ARE THOSE ARE
TYPICALLY COME.
COMMUNITY BASED OR OR MORE
LOOKING AT PROXIMITY TO THE
COMMUNITIES AND PROTECTION OF
LIVES AND PROPERTY THE FOREST
HEALTH --
APPLICATIONS ARE FOR OUR FURTHER
OUT IN THEIR THEIR FOREST HEALTH
AND RESILIENCE --
PROJECTS ALL OF THEM ARE ARE
GEARED TOWARD FOREST HEALTH AND
AND RESILIENT FORESTS.
BUT THEY HAVE A DIFFERENT
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE IN THAT
WILL IN ONE AREA WE'RE TRYING TO
PURCHASE FIRST.
WE'RE TRYING TO PROTECT
WATERSHED AND ON THE AND NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT.
AND THEN THE OTHER PLACE WERE
TRYING TO PROTECT THE THE
COMMUNITY.
AND TO DO THE OTHER ALL OF THESE
ARE SYSTEMATIC --
SYSTEMATICALLY AND HOLISTICALLY --
DEPENDED ON EACH OTHER FOR FOR A
HEALTHY FOREST ECOSYSTEM WITH
HUMANS RESIDING WITHIN.
IN MY FINAL QUESTION BEFORE THAT
SHOULD HAVE BEGUN BY SAYING
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL THE
HARD WORK.
OF YOURSELF AND ALL OF THE FIRST
RESPONDERS.
IT'S I AM PROUD TO HAVE YOU
LEADING INTO TO KNOW THAT --
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE IN GOOD
HANDS THANK YOU FOR ALL THAT
HARD WORK.
THANK THAT MIGHT MY FINAL
QUESTION IS WITH WITH THE
MONEY'S COMING IN FROM THE PC --
BOTH OF THE FROM PIECING CAL
FIRE -- WHAT
ARE WE DOING TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DON'T DUPLICATE?
EFFORTS SO THAT IT WE DON'T USES
THE SAME --
FUNDING FOR WHAT YOU USE FUNDING
WITH DIFFERENT SOURCES FOR THE
SAME THING WHAT ARE WE DOING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
DUPLICATING THE WE USE THAT YOU
WERE USING THE MONEY IN THE BEST
WAY POSSIBLE.
MEMORIES OF ANOTHER VERY FINE
QUESTION.
WE WE ARE COORDINATING OUR GRANT
PROGRAMS AND IT'S NOT JUST BE
YOU SEE --
TO SEE IF YOU SEE AND CAL FIRE
BUT ALSO --
OUR OTHER --
SISTER DEPARTMENTS IN WE WE ARE
WORKING TOGETHER TO COORDINATE
OUR GRANT PROGRAMS SO THAT THEIR
COMPLIMENTARY --
NOT SILOS BUT ALSO LOOKING AT AT
AREAS WHERE WE CAN HELP FUND
PROJECTS THAT THAT --
FIND THAT THAT FIND A WAY.
TO DEVELOP A CRITICAL MASS OF
GOOD WORK IN.
IN WATERSHEDS THAT NEEDED AND
AROUND COMMUNITIES THAT NEED.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
THEN WHY DON'T WE MOVE ON TO THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS.
OR PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
OKAY TO PREVENT THE SIX A
MORNING SERMON.
MY NAME IS LEE FIVE OR NOT I
KNEW WHERE HOW WE WERE --
ORDERING THESE.
MY NAME IS LEE PALMER I'M THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US TODAY --
I'M GONNA BUILD OFF OF A CHIEF
PORTER SAID I SPOKE --
TO SHORT STATEMENT WITH REGARD
SIR BCP --
CALIFORNIA IS EXPERIENCING
INCREASINGLY DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES THAT THREATEN THE
LIVES AND PROPERTY OF ITS
CITIZENS AND SB NINE A ONE IS AN
EXPANSE OF WATER FOR A BILL THAT
PRESENTS A COMPREHENSIVE WHILE
FOR PREVENTION AND RECOVERY
PACKAGE AIMED AT STRENGTHENING
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY. TO
MITIGATE AND RECOVER FROM
CATASTROPHIC Là SB NINE A ONE
PROVISIONS RELATED TO ITS
AUTHORITY.
THE PC REQUEST SIX POINT SIX
MILLION AND THIS BCP FOR A TOTAL
OF THIRTY FOUR POSITIONS.
SB NINE ONE ESTABLISHES SO WHEN
YOU REQUIREMENTS THAT WILL
RESULT IN MULTIPLE OVERLAPPING
AND ONGOING PROCEEDINGS.
ARE THESE PROCEEDINGS INCLUDE
DEVELOPMENT APPROVAL HE TOLD YOU
ARE FAR MITIGATION PLANS ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS.
EVALUATIONS OF THE UTILITY
SUCCESS IN IMPLEMENTING THEIR
PLANS.
EVALUATION OF UTILITY COSTS
RELATED TO IMPLEMENTING WATER
MEDICATION MEASURES.
I DON'T ENFORCEMENT PROCEEDINGS
FALLING PLAN ADOPTION.
RECOVERY OF COSTS CAUSED BY
WILDFIRES AND FINALLY FINANCIAL
REGULATION WHICH INCLUDES THE
REVIEW OF THE UTILITIES ABILITY
TO ABSORB COSTS.
AND ISSUANCE OF FINANCE
FINANCING ORDERS WHEN COSTS ARE
SCRUTINIZED.
IN ADDITION TO THE PROCEEDINGS
SB NINE A ONE REQUIRES THE PC TO
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPAND COMPLIANCE
AND ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES.
REQUIRING AN INCREASE IN PC
STAFF WITH SPECIFIC SETS OF
EXPERTISE I'M NOT GONNA GO INTO
THE STAFF FEATURES I'M MORE
HAPPY -- TO
I KNOW WHAT YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF
YOU BUT MORE ATTITUDE --
AGAIN SB NINE ONE ESTABLISHES AN
ONGOING COMMITMENT TO THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA --
PAST SUCH PERMANENT POSITIONS
ARE REQUIRED AND VITAL TO
INSURER UTILITY WATER MITIGATION
AND RESPONSE MEASURES ARE
EVALUATED AND FORCED AND
ADDRESSED IN A TIMELY MANNER.
I COMPLETE MY STATEMENT ANY
QUESTIONS FROM.
THANK YOU OF I'M NOT SURE FOR A
PUBLIC ADVOCATE WAS PLANNING ON
MAKING A STATEMENT.
THIS IS THE ARE --
FIRST FREE FORM HEARING OF THE
OF THE YEAR.
YOU SEE RIGHT HERE.
I'M COMING BACK.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN LIMóN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH ACKLES
DIRECTOR OF THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE AT THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
AND I'M WITH HERE HERE WITH
DOCTOR NATHANIEL SKINNER WHO IS
A SUPERVISOR OVER OUR SAFETY
SECTION.
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ON OUR
BUDGET CHAIN TO PROPOSALS
ASSOCIATED WITH SB NINE A ONE WE
ARE REQUESTING FOURTEEN NEW
POSITIONS TEN NEW STAFF
POSITIONS AND FOR ATTORNEYS. TO
HELP IMPLEMENT THE WILD FIRE
SAFETY AND WILD PARK COST
RECOVERY PROVISIONS OF SB NINE A
ONE AS YOU KNOW SB NINE A ONE
INSTITUTED SIGNIFICANT NEW
REQUIREMENTS UPON THE SIX
INVESTOR OWNED ELECTRIC
UTILITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
THE SIGNIFICANT NEW REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE PURPOSES OF OUR OFFICE
ARE IN TWO MAIN AREAS WILD FIRE
SAFETY AND WILD FOR COST
RECOVERY.
EACH OF THESE EFFORTS HAS
STATUTORILY MANDATED TIME LINES
AND FREQUENCIES THAT REQUIRE US
TO INCREASEOUR STAFFING TO MEET
OUR LEGISLATIVE MANDATE UNDER
PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE THREE OH
NINE POINT FIVE WHICH IS TO
OBTAIN THE LOWEST POSSIBLE.
RATE FOR SERVICE CONSISTENT WITH
SAFETY AND RELIABILITY. TWENTY
FIRST TO THE WILD FOR SAFETY WE
REQUESTED FIVE NEW POSITIONS TO
REPRESENT RATE PAYERS AND THE
CPC'S WILD FIRE MITIGATION PLAN
PROCEEDINGS.
THIS REQUIREMENT WILL REQUIRE
THE EQUIVALENT OF TWELVE NEW
PROCEEDINGS A YEAR IN WHICH WILL
BE PARTICIPATING STARTING IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ON NOTE THAT WE
HER FILING OR OUR FIRST COMMENTS
IN THAT WOULD UTILITIES WATER
MITIGATION PLANS TODAY.
AND GOING FORWARD THESE
POSITIONS COMPLETELY EVALUATE
AND MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
ENSURE RIGHT PAIR INTERESTS ARE
PROTECTED.
TURNING TO THE WILDFIRE COSTS
AND FINANCIAL SECURITIZATION
WE'VE REQUESTED FIVE NEW
POSITIONS TO CONDUCT FINANCIAL
ECONOMIC AND POLICY ANALYSIS OF
THE REASONABLENESS OF UTILITY
COSTS REQUESTS.
AS WE'VE ALREADY DISCOVERED IN
THE REVIEW OF P. GENIES WILD
FIRE MITIGATION PLANS AND THEIR
TWENTY TWENTY GENERAL RATE CASE
APPLICATION THERE'S EXTENSIVE
OVERLAP.
FROM A PROGRAMMATIC PROJECT AND
COST BASIS CONSISTENT WITH OUR
STATUTORY MANDATE WE MUST ENSURE
THE UTILITIES COSTS ARE
REASONABLE AND THEY'RE NOT
SEEKING COST RECOVERY FOR THE
SAME PROGRAMS.
IN DIFFERENT PROCEEDINGS THE
STAFF WILL ALSO PERFORM THE
ANALYSES ASSOCIATE WITH RATE
PAYER PROTECTION FINANCING UNDER
SECTION.
EIGHT FIFTY FINALLY REQUESTED
FOR SENIOR COUNSEL POSITIONS TO
PROVIDE LEGAL SUB SUPPORT IN
PREPARING DISCOVERY PREPARE
BRIEFS AND DEALING WITH THE
NECESSARY LEGAL --
ASPECTS OF OUR ADVOCACY.
AND THESE POSITIONS HAVE BEEN
REQUESTED IN COORDINATION WITH
THE COMMISSION'S LEGAL DIVISION.
THE STAFF POSITIONS ARE
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
EFFECTIVELY ADVOCATE ON BEHALF
OF RATE PAYERS AND MEET THE
PRECEDING SCHEDULES AND TIMING
REQUIREMENT AND SB NINE A ONE
THANKS AGAIN FOR BEING HERE FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY
AND WE ARE.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU --
ANY OTHER PRESENTATIONS.
BOB I HAVE SOME QUESTIONS --
A FIRST TERM.
I'M WONDERING IF THE COMPLIANCE
FUNCTION --
SO WITH THAT WE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER HOUSING THAT --
HI AT A AT ANOTHER DEPARTMENT
LIKE CAL FIRE SINCE THE EFFORTS
THAT ARE FOCUSED ON UTILITY
COMPLIANCE WITH THE WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLANS.
HI THAT ARE INTENDED TO HELP
AVOID WILDFIRES IS MIGHT BE MORE
ALIGNED WITH THE WORK THAT CAL
FIRE IS CURRENTLY DOING.
AND IS THAT AN INSURANCE FOR YOU
YEAH.
I'M THAT GERMAN SO IT IT THANKS
FOR THE QUESTION --
INSIDE OF THE B. C. P. FOR A THE
ENFORCEMENT OF IT COMPLIANCE ARE
REQUESTING ELEVEN POSITIONS
WITHIN OUR STATE ENFORCEMENT
DIVISION --
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE THREE AND THE
STAFF WORK CLOSELY WITH CAL FIRE
READY TO ANIMAL YOU THROUGH THE
WORKING GROUP.
ON A DAILY BASIS --
TO INCLUDE CELLS --
I THOUGHT VITAL THAT THE PC HAVE
THE SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS OF
THE UTILITIES WHICH WE CURRENTLY
POSSESS --
TO ACTUALLY GO OUT THERE AND
ASSIST CAL FIRE IS NEEDED AND
RECEIVE CALPERS INPUT --
BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT IT'S VITAL
THAT WE HAVE OUR OWN BOOTS ON
THE GROUND THERE CAN BE ABLE TO
GO OUT TO THESE LOCATIONS AND
ENSURE COMPLIANCE OF THE
UTILITIES PLANS.
OKAY WELL OF THANK YOU ACT OF
THIS THIS ITEM IS BEING HELD
OPEN --
SOLVE ALASKA'S STAFF --
TO YOU KNOW JUST INQUIRE LITTLE
BIT MORE DEEPLY INTO THAT --
AND AND REPORT BACK TO ME AND
THE AND THE COMMITTEE --
MY NEXT QUESTION IS --
THE POSITIONS [inaudible]
AND TO CHAU ARE --
ARE REQUESTING A PERMANENT --
AND NOT OF LIMITED TERM.
SINCE YOU.
PROBABLY THERE'S PROBABLY SOME
UNCERTAINTY AT THIS TIME AS TO
THE YOU KNOW HOW THOSE POSITIONS
Là ACTUALLY WORK OUT WHY ARE
THEY ALL.
PERMANENT INSTEAD OF SOME OF THE
MAIN LIMITED TERM OR MAYBE ALL
OF THEM BEING LIMITED --
TO RIGHT WELL WE ARE REQUESTING
PERMANENT POSITIONS BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATION WILL IN EFFECT
REQUIRE TWELVE NEW PROCEEDINGS A
YEAR OR REALLY SUB PARTS OF THAT
A LARGER PROCEEDING BUT IN
EFFECT TWELVE NEW PROCEEDINGS A
YEAR AND SO WE NEED.
THE FOLKS TO STAFF THAT THAT'S
AN ON AN ANNUAL BASIS ON GOING --
AND YOU KNOW AS FAR AS WE KNOW
PERMANENTLY BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
THE LEGISLATION REQUIRES SO
THAT'S WHY WE ARE REQUESTING
PERMANENT POSITIONS.
I AM AND MY BECAUSE OF PCA AYE
IT'S AN ONGOING PROCESS YOU KNOW
THAT WE WERE GETTING THE FIRST
PLANS THIS YEAR WE EXPECT THOSE
PLANS ARE GOING TO DEVELOP AND
CHANGE OVER TIME WITH EACH YEAR
AS WE LEARN BEST PRACTICES AND
DEVELOPING.
ALSO BASED ON THE SITUATION I
MEAN CLIMATE CHANGE TO GROW
INFRASTRUCTURE IS GOING TO
CONTINUE TO AGE AND OTHER THINGS
ARE HAPPENING IN ADDITION WITH
WHAT WE NEED TO TO ACCOMPLISH
THROUGH SB NINE A ONE IT'S AN
ANNUAL ONGOING REQUIREMENT.
THAT WE DO NOT SEE GOING AWAY AM
I CORRECT IT --
THAT ANOTHER WAY OF OF OF SAYING
THAT IS THAT YOU EXPECT THE NEED
ONLY TO GROW THEREFORE YOU
PROBABLY NEED MORE POSITIONS AS
TIME GOES ON THE POTENTIAL IS
THERE.
THE CLUB SO I THINK THAT THAT'S
THE THE ISSUE THAT I'M TRYING TO
GET OUT OF ITS ONLY POTENTIAL --
IT WOULD SEEM THAT THERE SOME
UNCERTAINTY IN THE WORKLOAD AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW IT
MIGHT DEBT BUT MICHAEL UP AND
AND I DO NOT.
I DO NOT BELIEVE IT OR DEBT --
I BELIEVE THAT WILL CONTINUE AND
STEADY STATE IF NOT INCREASE --
FOR IT TO CLEAR REASONS OF AGAIN
CLIMATE CHANGE AND AN EXPANDING
POPULATION AND EXPANDING
FOOTPRINT ON OUR STATE.
AND AS NEW COMMITTED TO
COMMUNITIES ARE BELT AND THE
WILD LAND SUBURBAN INTERFACE
GROWS.
THE NEED FOR INCREASED STAFF
WILL PROBABLY GROW WITH THAT.
IT'S GOING TO NEED TO ENSURE
THAT THE TOYS ARE ACTUALLY LIVE
AND IF I IN THIS ADD TO THAT WE
KNOW BASED ON SB NINE OH ONE
THAT AT A MINIMUM.
EVERY UTILITY THE THREE BIG ONES
AND THE THREE SMALL ONES NEED TO
FILE THEIR PLANS EVERY YEAR BOTH
THEIR WILD FOR MITIGATION PLAN
AND THEN IN ADDITION THERE'S
GOING TO BE A COMPLIANCE REVIEW.
SO THAT IN EFFECT IS GOING TO BE
TWELVE PROCEEDINGS EVERY YEAR --
IN IT ASIDE FROM WHETHER THE THE
NEEDS WILL GROW BUT WE KNOW AT A
MINIMUM WE HAVE WE WILL HAVE
THAT WORK LOAD ON GOING.
ALL RIGHT THAT'S PERFECT SEGUE
TO MY NEXT QUESTION WHICH IS --
WHICH OF THE UTILITIES HAVE --
FILED THEIR WILDLIFE MITIGATION
PLANS AT AT THIS ALL OF THEM SO
FAR.
AND AND WHAT'S THE STATUS OF OF
THE PC REVIEW AND WHEN CAN WE
EXPECT THAT REPORT ON US WE ARE
FINALLY IN OUR COMMENTS TODAY
COMMENTS ARE DUE TODAY AND THEN
I'LL LET YOU ADDRESS AT CPAC
SIDE SO THEY ARE CURRENTLY IN
REVIEW --
WITH AN EXPECTED APPROVAL DATE
IN MAY TO MEET THE NINETY NINE
NINETY DAY DEADLINE PUT IN SB
NINE A ONE WE RECEIVE INITIAL
COMMENTS --
AND CONTINUING --
TO WE HAVE HELD THE BOTH
WORKSHOPS WHERE THE UTILITIES
GOT TO CALM AND EXPLAIN THEIR
PLANS PRESENT THEM --
AND CONNECT YOU AN A ON IT SORT
OF CURRENTLY IN REVIEW I'M A
STAFF DEDICATED AT THE PC --
WE HAVE NINETEEN STAFF TOTAL
RIGHT NOW THAT ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER ARE WORKING WILD FIRE
MITIGATION OR INVESTIGATORY
EFFORTS RIGHT NOW.
I'M OUT OF OUR SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT ALONG I'M ENERGY
DIVISION OTHER STATUS
DISSIPATING AND THE REVIEW OF
THE PLANS.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS MISTER
PATTERSON.
GOV FOLLOW UP TO THAT QUESTION
I'M JUST ASKING STRAIGHT OUT
WILL THESE PLANS BE APPROVED ON
TIME YES OR NO YES.
THANK YOU.
A COUPLE OTHER AT POINTS I'M.
I MUST SAY I'M A LITTLE BIT
CONFUSED WITH RESPECT TO
PRIORITIES WITHIN THE THESE
BCP'S.
SO NOTICING IN YOUR BUDGET A
CHANGE PROPOSAL.
YOU RANK WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND
RECOVERY.
AS NUMBER FIFTEEN IN THAT RANKED
LISTING.
HOWEVER THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE.
LISTS IT AS A NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY.
SO MY FIRST QUESTION IS ARE WE
SUPPOSED TO READ ANYTHING INTO
THIS.
RANKING DISPARITY WITH RESPECT
TO HOW HIGH YOU PLACE.
THE WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND AND
RECOVERY.
I NOTICE IN THE B. C. P..
THAT THEY'RE UP [inaudible]
APPARENTLY INVESTIGATING --
GARAGE DOOR OPENERS.
IS A HIGHER PRIORITY IN THAT
LISTING.
THEN THIS.
ONE SO YOU NEED TO EXPLAIN TO ME
WHY WE HAVE THIS DISCREPANCY
BETWEEN THE PUBLIC.
ADVOCATE RANKING THIS AS THE
MOST IMPORTANT AND THE P. YOU
SEE RACKING AT AT FIFTEENTH
AMONG WHAT TWENTY OR TWENTY FIVE
THE REQUEST.
HELP ME UNDERSTAND. FOR ME
UNLESS YOU HAVE SOME KIND OF
EXPLANATION FOR THIS.
THIS TELLS ME THAT WHAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING RIGHT NOW IS RANKED
VERY LOW ON YOUR PRIORITY LIST.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION IT
ACTUALLY IS NOT RANKS LOW --
IN TERMS OF THE PUBLIC DOES
COMMISSION ORDER OF PRIORITY IT
IS A TOP PRIORITY OF THE
COMMISSION AS OF MOVE IT HAS
BEEN FOR ALMOST TWO YEARS NOW
WE'VE BEEN LOOKING SQUARELY AT
WILD FIRES DEDICATING RESOURCES
DIRECTLY TO THE WATERS AND SO
WHO ARE WE TO SAY THAT THE
RANKINGS.
HAVE ARE MEANINGLESS AT THAT
THAT OF THE TWENTY OR TWENTY
FIVE LISTED RIGHT THERE THEY'RE
ALL CO EQUAL.
WITH RESPECT TO THE ENERGY FOCUS
AND TIMELINESS OF THE PC.
WE DO OUR BEST TO BE TIMELY AND
EVERY ASPECT THAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING.
WE DO PRIORITIZE.
WILD FIRES RIGHT NOW ARE THE TOP
PRIORITY THE TOP PRIORITY OF THE
STATE THE TOP PRIORITY FOR
OURSELVES IN THE TOP PRIORITY
FOR THE STATE ENFORCEMENT
DIVISION AS WELL AS THE OTHER
DIVISIONS.
IN TERMS OF THE PRIORITY LIST
IT'S IN THE BCP --
I CAN SAY MAYBE IT WAS MISS PART
MAYBE THAT LIST WAS A BAD IDEA
MAY BUSINESS PRIVATIZED IN LIST
ITSELF.
BUT THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION IS TAKING
WATER PARKS EXTREMELY SERIOUSLY --
CAP.
THE ANSWER BUT WE ARE SITTING
HERE MAKING DECISIONS WITH
RESPECT TO PRIORITIZE LISTS.
AND YOU HAVE THIS RANKED VERY
LOW.
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHETHER
YOUR RANKINGS MEAN ANYTHING.
ARE WE SUPPOSED TO READ
SOMETHING INTO THIS WHY WOULD
YOU RANK THEM.
IF THAT DID NOT SIGNAL TO US.
A HIERARCHY OF PRIORITIES.
AND ALL I CAN SAY TO THAT IS
THAT RANKING LIST IS INCORRECT.
THAT THE RANK IT DOUBLY
IMPORTANT THING WANT A PIECE OF
WHAT CAN YOU UP LET'S ALLOW HIM
TO FINISH CATERING TO FIX THE
LIST PUT THIS ON THE TOP.
RIGHT AMOUNT LET'S I'M I'M DONE
LIKE IF ASK YOUR QUESTION I'M
DONE ASKING THE QUESTION AYE
FISHER ANSWER --
THE PLEASE PLEASE DO FINISH YOUR
ANSWER BARBARA I THANK JIM --
SO WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE WILD
FIRES BEYOND HAVING A DATE
DEDICATED STAFF IF WE HAVE
REALIZED THE P. YOU SEE.
THAT WE DO NOT HAVE THE RIGHT
PEOPLE B. AND FOR WHAT FIRE
MITIGATION AND INVESTED
INVESTIGATIONS.
WE WEREN'T DESIGNED FOR IT AND
WE LEARNED OUT THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN FIRES.
AND WE HAVE UTILITY ENGINEERS
AND POLICY ANALYSTS IN THE
SAFETY ENFORCEMENT DIVISION BUT
DO NOT HAVE WILD FIRE EXPERIENCE.
AND THAT'S WHAT'S LEFT VERY
CLOSE COORDINATION AND
RELATIONSHIP WITH CAL FIRE AND
UTILIZING THEIR WALLET FOR
EXPERTISE IN HELPING US
UNDERSTAND HOW THE WILD FIRES
ACTUALLY FUNCTION.
AND AS WE BECOME EDUCATED ON
THIS WE'VE REALIZED THESE ARE
THE SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS WE
NEED WE HAVE TO HAVE PEOPLE
DEDICATED THAT AREN'T YOU TOLD
THE ENGINEERS.
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE OUT
LOOKING AT UTILITY POLES OR
GENERATION FACILITIES OR GAS
PIPELINES AND THEN ON THE SIDE A
LITTLE WILD FIRES.
THEY NEED TO LOOK AT WILD FIRES.
COLLECTIVELY HOLY THAT IS THEIR
JOB THAT IS OUR SOLE PURPOSE AT
THE PC.
AND AS WILL BECOMING MORE
EDUCATED.
OUR PRIORITIES ARE CHANGING WERE
REALIZING HOW BIG THE PROBLEM IS
AND HOW WE NEED TO ADDRESS IT.
TURN AYE AYE YOU ANSWERED THE
QUESTION THAT IT WAS A MISTAKE.
DO YOU INTEND TO CHANGE THE
RANKINGS FOR FUTURE
DELIBERATIONS BY THIS COMMITTEE
OR THE LARGER BUDGET COMMITTEE.
AND I'LL HAVE TO TAKE THAT BACK
TO ENSURE THAT WE THAT WE MAKE
SURE WE STAND BEHIND UNLESS I
NEED TO TAKE THAT BACK THROUGH
MY LEADERSHIP AND ENSURE THAT WE
TAKE A HARD LOOK AT IT.
AND IF A CHANGE DOZEN YOU MADE
WE MAKE A CHANGE IN THE SENATE.
I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THAT
UP.
THANK YOU.
HAVE A QUESTION MAY DECIDE THAT
A RANKING SYSTEM IS IT
APPROPRIATE --
TO HI A TO THIS KIND OF RESPONSE
[inaudible]
AS FAR [inaudible]
OKAY -- I
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
LET'S SET TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
NOW -- WE'RE
GOING THROUGH THIS ENTIRE ITEMS
THANKS.
EVERYBODY WHO JUST STARTED TO
GET UP SORRY ABOUT THAT.
WILL MOVE ON TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
[inaudible]
CONSERVATION CORPS.
YOU'RE THE CHAIRMAN YOU CAN GO
OVER.
ONE I THANK I CAN CALL WHOEVER I
WANT I DON'T KNOW THAT I'LL GET
A RESPONSE.
SHARE WOULD IT BE HELPFUL TO GO
THROUGH THE REMAINING ORDER OF
THE DEPARTMENTS --
OR MAYBE YOU WANT TO CALL THEM
UP.
SURE I'M I'M HAPPY TO DO SO
[inaudible]
MISSION.
RIGHT NEXT WILL BE HEARING FROM
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS I THEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE FOLLOWED BY
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD AND THE WILL AND
WITH THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
PERFECT THANK YOU.
WATERS OUT.
THROUGH THE SIDE DOOR CALIFORNIA.
CONSERVATION CORPS THIS PROPOSED
BUDGET --
UNDER SB NINE WONDERS FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR CONSERVATION
COURSE THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO
DO FEELS REDUCTION IN HEALTHY
FORCE.
FOR OF THERE IS ALSO --
OUR FIRE FIGHTING --
CAPACITY OR FIRE PREVENTION WORK
THAT WE DO.
ACCEPT ANY FIRE PROTECTION WORK
WE DO FROM OUR CURRENT SEVEN
CREWS. TO TWELVE CREWS AT OUR
BUTTE PLASTER CAMERI --
I WOULD ADD A NEW SITE AT OUR
LOS PARCHES SOUNDS VISIBLE
CENTER -- SO
THAT THOSE CREWS ARE DURING
PROTECTION WORK BUT OF COURSE IF
THERE EVER IS A NON FIRE
FIGHTING SEASON.
OF THEY WOULD DO HEALTHY FORESTS
RULES WORK AND THEN FINALLY --
UNDER S. B. R. A. B. --
TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX OF THEIR
BEFORE FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WERE THAT.
FOR FUELS REDUCTION HEALTH
FORCED CREW WORK OF AT ONE CREW
OUT IT WITH WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR LOCAL.
CONSERVATION CORPS GREATER VALUE
CONSERVATION COURT AND STOCKTON --
A CREW IS FIFTEEN CORPS MEMBERS
AND OUR CREW SUPERVISOR.
WE'D ADD A FUELS A FORESTRY CORE
CREW AT ARE AT THIS LOCAL COURSE
SIDE STOCKTON ONE CRUDER CCC
INLAND EMPIRE SITE.
AND TO CREWS STILL TO BE
DETERMINED BUT THEY'D BE --
ASSIGNED TO A THAT'S OUR I THINK
ALL OF WHAT'S INCLUDED AND OUR
REQUEST FOR CITIES CITY TWO CREW
ADDITIONAL FIRE PROTECTION AND
PREVENTION WORK.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS.
RIGHT WHEN WE MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT PART SEVERAL CALL AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
[inaudible]
TO GREAT TABLE.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS CHUCK BOTTOM I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
OUR DEPARTMENTS BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL IS SPECIFIC.
AND FOR A VERY DEFINED PURPOSE.
OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE SUFFICIENT
CAPACITY TO MEET OUR ROLE IN THE
BROADER EFFORT THAT IS CREATED
THROUGH SENATE BILL NINE A ONE I
WOULD ALSO JUST NOTE FOR THE
RECORD.
THE CATASTROPHIC FIRES
IDENTIFIED IN THE STAFF AGENDA
AND MENTION BY THE CHIEF.
AFFECTED OUR DEPARTMENT AS WELL.
THEY THREATENED OUR FACILITIES
IN OUR INFRASTRUCTURE SOMETIMES
WILDLIFE AREAS AN ECOLOGICAL
RESERVES.
I MADE PHONE CALLS TO STAFF
WHO'VE LOST PROPERTY.
AND HOMES --
OVER THE COURSE OF THESE
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS.
THEY'VE IMPACTED FISH AND
WILDLIFE.
AND OFTEN SOME OF OUR STAFF WHO
LOST HOME AND PROPERTIES WERE
THEMSELVES FIRST RESPONDERS.
AS OUR WARDENS ASSIGNED TO THE
CHIEF. TO HELP EXPAND HIS FORCE
IN THE STAR MOMENTS.
THE PURPOSE --
IS STRAIGHTFORWARD AND PROPOSALS
SPECIFIC.
WE SICK FIFTEEN POSITIONS.
AND A TOTAL OF THREE MILLION
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
OF WHICH ONE MILLION FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE THOUSAND IS
GENERAL FUND.
AND TWO MILLION IS FROM THE
TIMBER REGULATION AND FOREST
RESTORATION FUND WHICH I'LL
MENTION AT THE END OF MY REMARKS.
THIS IS ONE OF THE SMALLER
AMOUNTS REQUESTED COMPARED TO
ALL THE OTHER INDIVIDUAL --
PROPOSALS IN THE GLOBAL PACKAGE.
THE PURPOSE --
IS VERY DEFINED.
WE WILL SEE AN INCREASE IN
WORKLOAD.
SENATE BILL NINE A ONE REQUIRES
OUR DEPARTMENT TO REVIEW NOTICES
OF EXEMPTION.
SENATE BILL NINE A ONE INCREASE
CREATES NEW POSSIBLE EXEMPTIONS
AND EXCEPTIONS --
WE WILL BE REQUIRED TO ASSESS
IMPACTS THE SPECIES ARE NATURAL
RESOURCES WERE REQUIRED TO HELP
CAL FIRE IN COMPLIANCE
MONITORING.
AND REPORTING POST INSPECTIONS.
WE HAVE OUR OWN PERMITTING
RESPONSIBILITIES RELATED TO
THESE --
EXEMPTIONS THAT WILL NEED TO BE
EXPEDITED.
AND AS AN EXAMPLE OF AN ADVISORY
ROLE.
THE BOARD OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION HAS ALREADY
IMPLEMENTED ITS EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS PURSUANT TO SENATE
BILL NINE A ONE AND THOSE
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS RELY
HEAVILY ON OUR DEPARTMENT FOR
POST PROJECT MONITORING.
AND PRE PROJECT CONSULTATION.
NONE OF WHICH HAS FUNDING SHORT
OF THE PROPOSAL IN FRONT OF YOU.
SO LET ME TURN IN CONCLUSION TO
SOME ITEMS YOU MAY HEAR IN
PUBLIC COMMENT AND THAT COME UP
IN YOUR AGENDA ON PAGE.
FOURTEEN THE TIMBER REGULATION
FORCE RESTORATION FUND IS
MANAGED.
BY THE NATURAL RESOURCE AGENCY
NOT THE DEPARTMENT.
I DON'T READ THE STAFF AGENDA TO
SAY IT'S AN INAPPROPRIATE FUNDS
SOURCE.
I READ THE STAFF AGENDA TO
QUESTION THE FUND BALANCE STATUS
OVER TIME.
SO I THINK THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND RESOURCE AGENCY --
ARE THE KIND OF BEST POSITION TO
ANSWER THAT I WILL TELL YOU.
THAT THAT FUND --
COVERS OUR WORK AROUND TIONS.
AND CREATE STATUTORY
PROHIBITIONS WE'RE WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO CHARGE FEES FOR THAT
TYPE OF WORK.
IN THE ABSENCE OF THE ABILITY TO
CHARGE FEES.
WE'RE LOOKING AT GENERAL FUND
AND THIS FUND TO SUPPORT THE
WORK WE NEED TO DO WONDER SENATE
BILL NINE A ONE I'LL STOP THERE
AND SEE IF THERE ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU I I THINK YOU --
FOR TOUCH TO IN YOUR A CLOSING
COMMENTS THERE ON THE ISSUE THAT
I WANTED TO INQUIRE ON BUT I
PROBABLY BASED ON YOUR COMMENTS
SHOULD INQUIRE OF DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE --
RATHER THAN YOURSELF --
DIRECTOR BOTTOM --
SO --
THERE'S THE THIS --
A TIMBER REGULATION ENFORCED
GROW --
DIVERTING TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
TO PERFORM TIMBER HARVESTS.
PLAN EXEMPTION REVIEWS --
THE OUR ANALYSIS SHOWS THAT THAT
IS TRENDING IN A WAY THAT --
THE EXPENDITURES THE FUND IS --
TRENDING IN A WAY THAT
EXPENDITURES ARE GOING TO BE
GREATER THAN REVENUES SO.
ON HOW CAN WE SUPPORT DECIDED ON
WHAT BASIS.
YES SIR DRAG OUR DEPARTMENT
FINANCE SO JUST START OFF THE
TWO MILLION DOLLARS FORD PART OF
FISH WILDLIFE ARE FOR FIVE YEARS
SO THEY'RE NOT ONGOING BASIS TO
THE CLERK BY THAT POINT.
SO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DO THIS
TOMB --
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY YEAR AND
BALANCE IN THE FUND TO ABOUT
ELEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AND CURRENT LAW THE TH
THAT WISH --
MINIMUM RESERVE BALANCE OF FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS THAT MUST BE
ESTABLISHED WITHIN THAT FIND.
IN CASE THERE'S DROPS IN REVENUE
FOR WITH BUDGET OF INCLUDED FOR
FUNDING FOR CHRISTIAN WILDLIFE
IN THE THE FUND BUT THERE ARE
SOME OTHER OFFSETS ANTHEM
DECREASES IN EXPENDITURES IN THE
FIND.
ASSOCIATED WITH THEM LIMIT TERM
RESOURCES ARE DROPPING OFF SO
ACTUALLY IN NINETEEN TWENTY
THERE'S FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S LEFT EXPENDITURES THAN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN SO IT'S
ACTUALLY DECREASING AND TOTALED
VENTURES AND THE FUND --
THERE IS A STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE --
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT THE LEVEL
OF AUTHORITY IS BIRTH IS THE
REVENUE COMING IN HOWEVER THAT
STRUCK COMPELLED TO THE BAY
OVERSTATED BECAUSE OVER THE PAST
FEW YEARS?
THERE'S BEEN APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN ANNUAL
SAVINGS CORRECTLY IT IS PRETTY
CLOSE TO THE ABOUT COMING IN.
AND WE HAVE SEEN A PRETTY
CONSISTENT INCREASE IN REVENUE
AND ABOUT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY INCREASE IN REVENUE.
SO THIS SOMETHING THAT WE
DEFINITELY ARE CONTINUING TO
MONITOR --
AND HE VALLEY ON ANNUAL BASIS AT
THIS POINT --
YOU KNOW THE FUND IT DOES HAVE
ABOVE THE MINIMUM RESERVE LEVEL
AND WE DO THINK IT COULD SUSTAIN
THIS UP FIVE YEAR COST BUT
WALKING THROUGH THE VALLEY TO
FIND.
TAKES THAT IN THREE FOUR YEARS
WE SEE YOU KNOW GREATER ISSUE
THEN WE CAN LOOK AT OTHER
ALTERNATIVES EITHER BRING DOWN
THE COST OR SEE WHAT OTHER OTHER
THINK WE COULD DO TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE.
SO I TRIED TO FOLLOW MOST OF
THAT -- THAT
WAS A LOT IN A VERY SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME BUT YOUR CONCLUSION AS
THE FIVE YEAR PERIOD OF TIME THE
FUND WILL NOT GO NEGATIVE --
IS THAT YOUR CONCLUSION ALSO FOR
A LONGER TERM.
IF THE TREND CONTINUE AS WE HAVE
BEEN SAYING ORDER THE FIVE YEAR
PRAYED --
YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT TO BE A GOOD
SUSTAIN IT --
IN THE LONG RUN AT THE GOING TO
CONTINUE VALLEY ANY MONITORING --
YOU KNOW IT REALLY DEPENDS ON
THE REVENUE THE REVENUE KEEP ON
CLIMBING AS THEY HAVE BEEN THAT
WE SHOULD BE FINE BUT YOU KNOW
IT'S A PROTECTIVE ORDER THAT --
SAY YOU KNOW IN SEVEN OR EIGHT
YEARS WHAT WOULD BE THE REVENUE
BUT AT LEAST FOR THE FIVE YEAR
PERIOD IF THE TREND CONTINUE AS
WE ARE WITH.
THE ACTUAL LEVEL EXPENDITURE THE
REVENUES COMING IN THEN IT IT
SHOULD BE ABLE TO STAY IN IT ALL
RIGHT WELL --
THANK YOU --
AGAIN WE'RE HOLDING THIS OPEN AT
ALL ASK YOU TO HUDDLE WITH --
OUR STAFF TO GO OVER THOSE OF
PROJECTIONS THANK YOU MISTER
FONG.
I THINK IT WAS GERMAN THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE --
ALL ALL BUT A JUMP AROUND BUT
FOR AND IN TERMS OF THE B. C. B.
I KNOW THE SB NINE A ONE
REQUIRES --
OFFICIAL WILDLIFE TO TO REVIEW
THE NOSE OF EXEMPTIONS BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT --
THE ROLE THE EXAMS AS OUR
MINISTERIAL SO THAT THEY REQUIRE
YOUR DEPARTMENTS APPROVAL SO HOW
DO YOU RECONCILE THE FACT THAT
THERE'S THE NEED FOR MORE STAFF
WHEN.
IN ESSENCE CAL FIRE MAKES THOSE
DETERMINATIONS NOT FISH WILDLIFE.
HEY MY EXPERIENCE CAL FIRE IN
OUR DEPARTMENT HAVE A CLOSE AND
PRODUCTIVE RELATIONSHIP THAT
ALLOWS US TO MEET MULTIPLE
OBJECTIVES. ONE OF THOSE STATE
OBJECTIVES IS PROTECTING PUBLIC
TRUST RESOURCES.
I HEAR YOUR COMMENT AND EXCEPT
THE VIEW ABOUT THE MINISTERIAL
ASPECT [inaudible]
BUT SB NINE OH ONE CREATES A
BROAD PUBLIC POLICY ENDEAVOR --
TO DO THINGS BETTER AND FASTER
GIVEN THE RISK OF CATASTROPHIC
FIRE.
OUR DEPARTMENT PLAYS AN
IMPORTANT ROLE AS THE STATE'S
PUBLIC TRUST RESOURCE.
AGENCY WHEN IT COMES TO STREAM
CROSSINGS BECOMES A TEMPORARY
ROAD CONSTRUCTION.
AND I THINK OUR ABILITY TO
PARTICIPATE WELL IN THE REGIME
CREATED BY NINE A ONE IS SOUND
PUBLIC POLICY.
SO THE CONCERN THAT I HAVE IS
THAT IN TERMS OF INSERTING
ANOTHER DEPARTMENT INTO
SOMETHING WHERE IT CAL FIRE HAS
THE AUTHORITY TO APPROVE AND
THEN DISTRIBUTE THE EXEMPTIONS
THAT THAT DOES NOT MAKE THINGS
FASTER.
HE WOULD YOU GIVE US SOME
ASSURANCE THAT THESE THINGS
WOULD PROCEED FASTER AS MR PASS
INDICATED WILDFIRE PREVENTION IS
YOU SHOULD BE OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY.
YES I CAN GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
FOR SURE IT'S I'LL GIVE YOU BOTH.
LET ME GIVE YOU THE EXAMPLE
FIRST.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN I
BELIEVE [inaudible]
CALIFORNIE FIVE POSITIONS TO
FOCUSED ON POST EXEMPTION
MONITORING.
FUNDED FROM THE TIMBER FUND.
YOU'LL SEE IN OUR BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL A SPECIFIC INTERESTING
INCREASING OUR CAPACITY. FOR
POST EXEMPTION MONITORING IN
FACT.
THE BOARD OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTIONS EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS PURSUANT.
TO NINE ONE RELY ON OUR
DEPARTMENT HEAVILY TO HELP CAR
FIRE DO THE POST PROJECT
MONITORING.
AND PRE PROJECT CONSULTATION
GIVEN OTHER EXAMPLE ONE OF THE
BENEFITS OF NINE OH ONE THAT I
SEE.
IS THE ABILITY FOR SMALL TIMBER
OWNERS TO COME IN TO THE
CONSULTATION PROCESS AND BE ABLE
TO THEN GO OUT.
AND SEND THEIR FOREST ON SMALL
TIMBER PROPERTIES --
WHICH IS A DIFFERENT --
OF INVESTMENT FOR SMALL TIMBER
UNDERSTAND LARGER INDUSTRIAL
COMPANIES.
THEIR ABILITY TO DO THAT HINGES
ON OUR ABILITY TO CONSULT WITH
THEM AND ADVISE THEM.
SO I THINK THOSE ARE EXAMPLES OF
IMPROVING THE PROCESS.
EXPEDITING THE PROCESS WHICH
SHOULD RESULT IN MORE TEMPERATE
DEMINING DONE IN THE STATE TO
PREVENT FIRES HERE'S THE
INSURANCE.
AS DIRECTOR --
I WILL PAY CLOSE ATTENTION. TO
HOW WE USE THESE FIFTH FIFTEEN
POSITIONS AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO ASK US TO
COME BACK WITH PERFORMANCE
METRICS. TO SHOW YOU THE
INVESTMENT HAS PRODUCED THINGS
FASTER THAN I WOULD BE WILLING
TO STAND BY THOSE PERFORMANCE
MUCH OKAY AWESOME I APPRECIATE
THAT AND AND JUST FOR EXAMPLE
I'LL OF SAY THAT YOU'VE YOU'RE
REQUESTING A POSITION IN THE
SOUTH COAST REGION.
AND THE INLAND REGION I BELIEVE
THAT'S CORRECT AND IN THOSE
AREAS MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THERE'S PROBABLY BEEN ONE OR TWO
PLANS UNDER REVIEW.
SO DO YOU EXPECT.
AND AT A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
THOSE AREAS VERSE BECAUSE YOU'RE
ASKING FOR POSITIONS IN AREAS
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
WORK RIGHT NOW. ONE SECOND
BECAUSE OF LIKE TO LOOK AT THE
AGENDA.
FROM THE STAFF BUT OUR SOUTH
BECAUSE REGION.
AS WE DEFINED AS THE DEPARTMENT.
WOOD OR INCLUDES THE WALLS THE
FIRE VENTURA.
THE THOMAS FARM IT WAS IT WAS IT
WAS AND MALIBU IN SANTA MONICA --
ADVENTURE COUNTY IS EXCELLENT.
IN THE THOMAS FIRE WHICH IS
VENTURE IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY --
CATASTROPHIC FIRES HAPPEN IN OUR
SOUTH BECAUSE REGION WE WANT TO
BE PREPARED DIVERSE RESPOND ANY
REQUESTS FOR EXCEPTIONS
EXEMPTIONS AND GET THAT WORKED
ON OR IS THAT SOUTH BECAUSE IN
INLAND REGION --
FOR US.
ARE INLAND REGION --
RUNS INTO RIVERSIDE COUNTY SAN
MEDINA COUNTY --
WE AGAIN WANT TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND TO ANY REQUEST FOR
EXCEPTIONS AND EXEMPTIONS TO GET
THIS WORK DONE.
THERE ARE COMMUNITIES THAT BUMP
UP. TWO MOUNTAIN RANGES AND
FORESTED LAND.
OKAY WEBER AT THE END THE DAY
THE END OR NOT A WINE CAL FIRE
MAKES A DECISION.
WITH THE WITH THE MINISTERIAL AT
THIRTY THEY HAVE WE UNDERSTAND
THAT WE ARE HELPING CALL.
FOR OKAY --
IN TERMS OF THE BROADER ACCOUNT --
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE A I SEE ONE IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN I HAVE WE
HAVEN'T GOTTEN ONE I GUESS FROM
THE AS THE LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHEN WOULD BE ABLE TO
SEE THAT.
I WILL ASK THE RESOURCES AGENCY
AND WE WILL EXPEDITE THAT REPORT
TO THIS SUBCOMMITTEE OKAY AND
THEN TWENTY NINETEEN M. SWIMMING
IS BEING WORKED ON MY
UNDERSTANDING I WILL CHECK AND
GET BACK TO YOUR OFFICE.
IN TERMS OF THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
REPORT -- I
GUESS I'M WE'RE SEEING A
DISTURBING TREND ADDING FROM
OTHER THAT THAT'S PROBABLY
SIMILAR TO OTHER AGENCIES WHICH
IS STAFFING INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF PLANS APPROVAL PROCESS
TIME -- OR
PLANS BEING --
PLANS DIG DECREASING THE NUMBER
OF YOU KNOW --
YOU KNOW IT THE NUMBER OF PLANS
DO -- THE
THE TIME THE TIME LINE TO PROVE
THESE PLANS ARE INCREASING AS
WELL SO.
MY CONCERN IS THAT YOUR
INCREASING STAFF.
BUT THEN THE TIME TO REVIEW HIS
WHICH IS IS OFFICE OF A LONGER.
THE HOPE IS OF COURSE IF YOU
HIRE MORE STAFF THAT YOU WOULD
MAKE THINGS FASTER SO --
CAN YOU CAN YOU RECONCILE THAT
[inaudible]
YES.
I'D LIKE TO LOOK AT THE SAME
DATA YOU'RE LOOKING AT AND I
WOULD BE WILLING TO DO THE SAME
THING WITH THE COMPANIES --
THE COMPRISE THE CALIFORNIA
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION THEIR
LEADERSHIP.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT ALWAYS OBVIOUS
TO ME WE'RE SEEING THE SAME
TREND LINES.
I THINK WOULD BE VERY
CONSTRUCTIVE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE SAME DATA.
WELL THE OTHER RECONCILIATION I
WOULD MAKE IS.
SOME OF THE WORK YOU REFERENCE
IS WORK THAT IS PRE NINE OH ONE
WORK IT WILL NEED TO CONTINUE.
FOR TODAY WE'RE FOCUSED ON A
REQUEST ABOUT HAVING CAPACITYTO
DO THE NINE OH ONE WORK WELL.
RIGHT THE NIGHT WHEN WORK IS IS
BEING ADDED ON AND SO THAT'S I
GUESS LET ME CLARIFY IT IN TERMS
OF STAFFING CONTINUES TO GO UP
NOT A ONE OBVIOUSLY ADDS MORE
WORK.
YEAH THE NUMBER OF T. H. P.'S
APPROVED WENT DOWN THE NUMBER OF
ACRES BEING TREATED WHICH IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT PART HAS GONE
DOWN AND THE TIME IT TOOK TO
REVIEW THEM WENT UP.
SO THOSE THOSE TRENDS ARE
POSITIVE [inaudible]
CORRECT.
I WOULD LIKE TO LOOK AT THE SAME
DATA YOU'RE LOOKING AT AND I
WILL WELCOME AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION.
THIS MAKE SURE WE'RE SEEING THE
TREND LINES THE SAME BUT THE
INVESTMENT STAFF SHOULD BE
PRODUCING FASTER WORK PRODUCT.
AND DESIRED OUTCOMES SOONER.
OKAY AND THEN IN TERMS OF YOUR
VIEW AND MAYBE THE PART FINANCE
YOU CAN JUMP IN HERE I HEAR THE
WORDS --
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE IS THE FIND
GOING INSOLVENT.
SO AT THIS POINT OVER THIS NEXT
FIVE YEAR PERIOD --
THAT WE KIND OF LOOK AT AND THE
PRIZE THEN ADD THE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCE THE REQUESTING FOR FISH
AND WILDLIFE ARE OVER THIS FIVE
YEAR PERIOD.
IF THE TRENDS CONTINUE AS THEY
HAVE BEEN WITH THE KIND OF LEVEL
OF EXPOSURE COMING IN AND THE
AMOUNT OF REVENUE INCREASING
EACH YEAR WE SHOULD BE FINE BUT
IN THE LONG RUN YOU KNOW SEVEN
EIGHT TEN HEY --
IT REALLY DOES DEPEND ON THE THE
LEVEL OF REVENUE THAT CONTINUE
COMING IN AS A NEW LEVEL EXPAND
OR SO IF SOMETHING EVER DEFTLY
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE MONITORING
AND EVALUATING --
BUT AT THIS POINT FOR NEXT TWO
YEARS WE FEEL THAT THE FUND
COULD SUSTAIN THESE COSTS.
AND WE'RE DEFINITELY ABOVE THAT
MADE THEM --
THRESHOLD IN STATUE WHICH WAS
IDENTIFIED THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE
A MINIMUM OF FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS AT ALL TIMES IN THE FIND
OUR CURRENTLY AT ELEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
BUT IN TERMS OF THE THE THE THE
STAFF THE STAFF --
A STAFF ANALYSIS MADE
EXPENDITURES ARE EXCEEDING
REVENUES PRETTY SIGNIFICANTLY AT
THE MAIN THAT'S IT THAT'S
CORRECT.
THE DECLARE BY THE THE
AUTHORIZED LEVEL OF EXPENDITURES
ARE ABOVE THE ANNUAL REVENUE
HOWEVER WHEN WE GO BACK AND LOOK
AT THE ACTUAL LEVEL BECAUSE
THERE'S AN AUTHORIZED AMOUNT AND
THEN AFTER THE YEAR AND WE DO
ACTUAL.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY COOK A COMING
IN -- PRETTY
CONSISTENT AS THOUGH WHEN HE
JUST THAT'S WHY IT IN MY EARLIER
COMMENT.
I MENTIONED THAT THE STRUCTURE
BALLOT MAY BE OVERSTATED WHEN
YOU JUST LOOK AT THE LEVEL OF
AUTHORITY VERSUS LEVEL OF
REVENUE BECAUSE IN OUR KIND OF
PREVIOUS AND HEALTH OF THE PAST
FEW YEARS.
THE ACTUAL HAVEN'T BEEN COMING
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT WE HAVE
BEEN PROJECTING THEM TOO SO IT'S
ACTUALLY NOT.
AS MUCH OUT OF THE SPECTRUM
BALANCED AS YOU WOULD SEE IF YOU
JUST LOOK AT THE FINE CONDITION
BALANCE OF THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
F. N. AND THEN IT'S GONE TO
ELEVEN BILLION IN --
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY SO
THAT'S YOU KNOW A REDUCTION OF
NINETEEN MILLION DOLLARS.
SO IN HONOR THAT PATH.
THAT WOULD BE UNSUSTAINABLE
CORRECT.
I'M OUT ALL THOSE NUMBERS
INCORRECT.
THAT IN IN A IN A TWO YEAR
PERIOD WE'VE GONE DOWN NINETEEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
I WOULD HAVE TO GO BACK AND LOOK
AT WHAT WITH SPECIFICALLY
IDENTIFIED IN THE AGENDA WE
COULD PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION FOR YOU HAVE COULD
SEE WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT WHICH
LOOK AT THE ACTUAL TRAINS COMING
IN SO.
WE COULD DEFINITELY PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION TO THE STAFF AT THE
SHARE WITH YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
AND AT THE END OF MY MY FINAL ON
I GUESS.
MY FOR A SURE WINNER I GUESS
FOCUS ON IS THAT THE AND WE
WOULD AGREE THAT WE WANT TO
MAXIMIZE THE AMOUNT OF FUNDS
GOING INTO GRANTS AND TREATMENT
OF ACRES NOT STAFF [inaudible]
CORRECT [inaudible]
SO.
AB FOURTEEN NINETY TWO
IDENTIFIED A LEVEL OF PRIORITIES
FOR THE FIND AND THAT'S
CURRENTLY IN STATUTE.
AND THE PRIORITIES IS FIRST FOR
THE THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE DEPARTMENTS TO DO THE REVIEW
AND PERMITTING PROCESS FEES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE WITH A
TIMBER OPERATIONS SO THAT'S THE
FIRST LEVEL PRIORITY IN STATUTE.
THE STATUE THAT IDENTIFIES AFTER
THAT FIRST LEVEL PRIORITY IS MET.
IF THERE'S FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE FUND THEN WE CAN USE THAT
FOR GRANTS SO THERE IS THERE ARE --
FUNDING FOR GRANT'S WITHIN THESE
PROGRAMS WITHIN THE DEPARTMENTS --
HOWEVER THERE IS DEFINITELY LESS
BINDING BECAUSE WE ARE FOLLOWING
THE STATUE WHICH IDENTIFIES THE
PRIORITY LEVEL FOR THE FUNDS.
I YEARS WAS A THAT WE WOULD WANT
TO FLIP THAT THE PRIORITY RIGHT
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WE
MINIMIZE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
SPENT.
AND MAXIMIZING THE ENVIRONMENT
IMPACT IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE
THESE ACRE MORE ACRES ARE BEING
TREATED OF THE GRANTS RIGHT WE
WANT MORE MONEY TO GO OUT TO THE
GRANT.
AND LESS TO THE OVERHEAD CORRECT.
I WOULD OR MISS BY WOULD BE TO
SEE THAT YOU WANT TO CHIME IN
HERE TO WHERE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
MORE MONEY GOES OUT TWO TO THREE
ACRES AND NOT REALLY MUCH FOR
OVERHEAD.
WELL I DON'T ACCEPT THE PREMISE
THAT THE GRANTING PRODUCES MORE
ON THE GROUND RESULTS AND STAFF
CAPACITY.
NECESSARILY FOR EXAMPLE.
OUR DEPARTMENT PROJECTS
RECEIVING.
AN ONSLAUGHT OF REQUESTS FOR
EXEMPTIONS IN EXCEPTIONS.
WE EXPECT TO HELP CAL FIRE.
IF WE CAN PROCESS THAT WORKLOAD
THEN.
I THINK THE LOGIC FOLLOWS MORE
PEOPLE WILL BE OUT ON THEIR
FOREST LANDS DOING PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES BLACK BUT WE WANT
MORE MONEY TO GO INTO THE
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES.
AND STAFF CAPACITY.
CAN PRODUCE THAT RESULT AS WELL
OR BETTER THAN GRANT RESTORATION
FUNDING.
SAY THAT AGAIN SO YOU WOULD SAY
THAT.
THE THAT STAFFING IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN GRANT CAPACITY
[inaudible]
YOUR PREMISES.
USING FOUR MILLION DOLLARS TO
MAKE DISCREET.
RESTORATION FUNDING CHOICES.
WILL PRODUCE MORE LANDSCAPE
CHANGE DâN.
DEALING WITH THE INCOMING
REQUESTS FOR EXEMPTIONS.
I'M NOT CERTAIN THAT PREMISE
HOLDS.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE INCOMING
REQUESTS FOR EXEMPTIONS AND
EXCEPTIONS THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ABOUT.
TRYING TO GET BOOTS ON THE
GROUND FASTER AND TREATING OUR
FOREST ACROSS THE WHOLE STATE.
SO I THINK THERE'S A PRUDENT
DECISION. TO PREPARE FOR THAT
WORKLOAD AND RESPOND TO THAT
WORK LOAD.
THAT MAY PRODUCE MORE TREATMENT.
THEN HE SAID A DISCREET GRANT
FUNDING DECISIONS MAY.
MAY OKAY I I I I GUESS I DON'T
HAVE ALL THE NUMBERS I JUST WHEN
YOU SAY FOR MY AND WE HAVE TO
MAINTAIN A FOUR MILLION DOLLAR.
BALANCE CORRECT SO IF THERE'S
ELEVEN I WOULD WANT THAT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO MAKE TO GO
OUT TO GRANT OR AS MUCH OF IT AS
POSSIBLE SO THAT WE CAN MAINTAIN
IT FOR MINOR BALLOTS.
BUT IF WE ARE GOING TO EAT INTO
THE FOUR MILLION DOLLAR --
BALLOTS WE GOTTA MAINTAIN THEN
WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING.
TO EXACERBATE.
THE FUND THAT IS PAID FOR BY
FEES SO EITHER YOU SOLVE THIS
INSOLVENCY BY.
A FEE INCREASE WHICH I'M NOT
SURE THAT YOU GUYS REPAIRED TO
TO ENTERTAIN ARE OVER I WOULD
SUPPORT.
SO I I GUESS I'M JUST TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHEN WE
PRIORITIZE THINGS THAT WE MAKE
SURE THAT MORE MONEY GOES OUT TO
TREATING AREAS AND PREVENTING
WILDFIRES WHICH IS I THINK THE
THE THE PRIORITY OF EVERYONE ON
THIS COMMITTEE.
AND THEN GOING INTO A DELAYED
OVERSIGHT --
WHICH WOULD IS PROBABLY
UNNECESSARY BECAUSE IT'S
MINISTERIAL THAT'S I APPRECIATE
THE TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR ANSWERS.
MISTER PATTERSON.
I JUST QUIT THE FOCUS A BIT ON
THAT.
ACCORDING TO OUR REVIEW OF THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN REPORT FOR THE
TIMBER HARVEST PLANS.
THAT THIS PROCESS OF STAFF
GETTING OUT IN GETTING STUFF
DONE OUT THERE WITH BOOTS ON THE
GROUND --
WE'VE ACTUALLY SEEN THAT THAT
PLAN REVIEWS THIS IS A TWENTY
SEVENTEEN DECREASED.
THE NUMBER OF ACRES REVIEWED
DECREASED.
FULL TIME STAFF WORKING ON THESE
PLANS HAS INCREASED.
YET THE AVERAGE TIME OF REVIEW
FOR THE PLANS [inaudible]
HAS INCREASED.
THAT'S TWENTY SEVENTEEN DO YOU.
SUGGEST THAT YOUR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN REPORT.
WHAT HAVE HAD A DIFFERENT SET OF?
THINGS GOING UP AND THINGS GOING
DOWN.
I HAVE MADE NO SUGGESTION ABOUT
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN REPORT I
UNDERSTAND.
THAT PERSPECTIVE RELATIVE TO THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN REPORT.
I'VE SAID WITH REGARD TO THOSE
NUMBERS.
I'D LIKE TO SIT WITH YOU AND THE
TIMBER ASSOCIATION MAKE SURE
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE SAME DATA.
I TO SHARE AN INTEREST AND ALL
THE TREND LINES GOING UP IN
PRODUCTIVITY AND EFFICIENCY.
BUT THAT IS DIFFERENT THAN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RESPECTIVELY OUR
PROPOSAL TODAY.
WHICH IS ABOUT HOW TO PREPARE
FOR THE S. B. NINE NO ONE
RESPONSIBILITIES.
SO WE'RE HELPING CAUGHT FIRE
WE'RE HELPING INDUSTRY AND WE'RE
DOING MORE PREVENTION NOT LESS.
AT THIS IS A RECURRING.
THEME WITH MAY.
WHETHER IT'S ON THIS --
COMMITTEE OR OTHERS INCLUDING J.
LACK.
WE SEE REPEATEDLY.
REQUESTS FOR MORE STAFF.
BIGGER BUDGETS.
AND WHEN WE SEE HOW OTHER
DEPARTMENTS.
USE THOSE FUNDS AT ALL OF THE UP
ARCS OF PROGRESS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE GO THE OTHER WAY.
I CONTEND THIS IS ENDEMIC.
TO BUREAUCRACIES AD I GUESS MY
TAKE AWAY HERE IS.
I AM AT LEAST PLEASE THAT YOU
SEE THAT THOSE TREND LINES.
AS SERIOUS AND I WOULD TRUST AND
HOPE THAT THE MANAGEMENT OF THIS
DEPARTMENT --
WILL PRODUCE IN REPORTS FOR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN A SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT IN WHAT WE WANT TO
DO.
YOU'RE ASKING FOR US TO APPROVE.
AND WHEN WE DO.
RARELY DO WE SEE.
A SUBSTANTIAL IMPROVEMENTS FROM
THE PROBLEM THAT WAS --
PARAMOUNT AND WAS THE REASON FOR
THE INCREASED BUDGET.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THERE'S NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS OF MISTER
BONHAM THANK YOU.
MISS YOU IT WHO SEVERAL I HAVE
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD COMING PRESENT
THEIR PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS EILEEN SO BACK I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD --
THANK YOU --
FOR GIVING US AN OPPORTUNITY --
TO TO PRESENTER PROPOSAL TODAY --
WE THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD REQUEST TWENTY TWO
POSITIONS AND FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY NINETEEN THROUGH --
TWENTY WE OF COURSE SUPPORT OUR
HE'S AND A MISSION --
TO AS SET OUT IN IN SB NINE NO
ONE AND WE REALLY WANT TO MAKE
BE ABLE --
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT --
THAT ALL OF THE FIRE UP.
HELP PROTECTION --
AND AND FOREST RESILIENCY ISSUES
ARE ADDRESSED BUT IN A
RESPONSIBLE WAY THAT DOESN'T
HAVE UNINTENDED ADVERSE --
CONSEQUENCES TO OTHER POP --
IMPORTANT PUBLIC RESOURCES.
SO SINCE --
THE ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
AUTHORIZED AND REQUIRED --
UNDER SB NINE NO ONE WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE LAND
MANAGEMENT AND DISTURBANCE --
ACTIVITIES.
THERE ARE.
IT'S HARD TO KNOW HOW MUCH BUT
THERE ARE SOME POTENTIAL
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS. TO WATER
QUALITY ACROSS THE STATE'S
THIRTY THREE MILLION ACRES OF
FOREST LAND.
AND FORTY THREE THOUSAND MILES
OF UTILITY CORNER COURT
CORRIDORS.
SO THESE GROUND DISTURBING
ACTIVITIES --
WILL -- WILL
OCCUR IN SOME OF THE STATE'S
MOST IMPORTANT AND PRODUCTIVE
SOURCE WATERSHEDS.
AND THE WORK CONDUCTED HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO INCREASE SETTLEMENT
AND PESTICIDE DISCHARGES INTO
WATERS OF THE STATE. TO ALTER
FOREST AND STREAM CHANNEL
HYDROLOGY --
POTENTIALLY INCREASING AND
CONCENTRATING --
STORM WATER RUNOFF RESULTING IN
EROSION --
AND SEDIMENT DISTRICT JUSTICE TO
STREAMS POSSIBLE RISK TO
DOWNSTREAM INFRASTRUCTURE
INCLUDE INCLUDING ROADS AND
WATER SOURCE CROSSINGS --
AND DESTRUCTION CHEMICALS IN THE
FORM OF PETROLEUM AND PESTICIDE
PRODUCTS USED ADJACENT TO OUR UP
SLOPE OF THE SURFACE WATERS.
SO SUCH DISCHARGES --
DO HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO IMPACT
BENEFICIAL USES OF THE STATE'S
WATER -- FOR
EXAMPLE INCREASING SEDIMENTATION
CAN DIRECTLY IMPACT THE HEALTH
OF QUITE XP SEES.
AN AQUATIC HABITATS --
INCREASE --
INCREASING WATER TEMPERATURES
CAN CREATE HUMAN HEALTH HAZARDS
INCLUDING --
THOSE FROM HARMFUL ALGAL BLOOMS.
AND IT'S POSSIBLE THAT CLEAN
DRINKING WATER SUPPLIES CAN BE --
THREATENED OR COMPROMISE THROUGH
INCREASED SETTLEMENT AND
INTRODUCTION OF CHEMICAL
CONTAMINANTS --
UP BECAUSE OF THE ACTIVITIES
AUTHORIZED UNDER --
SB NINE A ONE THE WATER BOARD
WILL NEED TO DEVELOP A NEW
STATEWIDE GENERAL ORDER --
FOR OF WASTE JUST TRY TO
REQUIREMENTS FOR CONSTRUCTION
AND MAINTENANCE OF UTILITY CORPS
OF CORRIDORS AND ASSOCIATED
ACCESS ROADS.
AND WE WILL HAVE TO ESTABLISH A
SYSTEM FOR CONDUCTING FIELD
INSPECTIONS ASSOCIATED WITH
UTILITY QUARTERS AND MAINTENANCE.
AND THEN WE'LL HAVE TO INCREASE
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF FIELDS INSPECTIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH TIMBER HARVEST --
THE TIMBER HARVEST AN EXEMPTION --
BECAUSE THERE'S GOING TO BE A
LOT MORE TEMPORARY ROAD BUILDING
AND WITH NO PRE APPROVAL --
SO WE'RE GOING TO NEED --
TO AM RATIONAL INSPECTION SYSTEM
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE THE
POTENTIAL --
HARMS TO WATER SOURCES THAT I
MENTIONED --
DO NOT OCCUR A MOST OF THE
POSITIONS THAT WERE ASKING FOR
THE VAST MAJORITY WILL BE --
WOULD BE --
SEARCHED OUT TWO OF THE REGIONAL
WATER PORTS WHERE THE
INSPECTIONS --
OCCUR THERE FOR MEAN FOR
REGIONAL WATER PORTS IN WHICH
99% OF THE TIMBER --
TIMBERLANDS OCCUR SO THAT'S
WHERE -- WE
WOULD DEPLOY THE INSPECTION
RESOURCES --
THERE ARE A FEW POSITIONS WHICH
WOULD BE AT THE STATE WATER
BOARD TO DEAL WITH THE THE
UTILITIES AND THE THE GENERAL
PERMIT.
TO WORK.
THERE TWO SOURCES FOR THE
FUNDING THAT WERE --
REQUESTING --
THE UTILITY RELATED WORK --
WILL BE FEATURED RATED UNDER THE
BOARDS WASTE DISTRICT PERMIT
FUND -- BUT
AS MENTIONED BY DIRECTOR BONHAM --
THE THE REMAINDER OF THE FUNDS --
WE'VE IDENTIFIED AS BEING
APPROPRIATELY FROM THE GENERAL
FUND BECAUSE OF THE RESTRICTIONS
UNDER A. B. FOURTEEN NINETY TWO
REGARDING --
PROVISIONS ON ON A CHARGING FEES --
FOR ACTIVITIES AND TIMBER --
LANDS SO WITH THAT I'D BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS.
HI I DON'T SEE ANY SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
AND TO PROCESS OF ELIMINATION OF
BUT YOU'RE GONNA ASK CARE BE A
STEP FORWARD.
THANKS YOU'RE OFFICIALLY
APPOINTED.
TO SEVERAL HAVE NOT SURE WHAT IT
IS BUT THE CALLER.
WELCOME WELL AT THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN WOMEN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE EIGHT MY NAME
IS ET CHIANG A DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
OFFICER AT THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD.
I'M SO THE PRESS BEFORE YOU THIS
MORNING IS PURSUANT TO SB TWELVE
SIXTY AND IT WILL HELP BUT CARP
IMPLEMENT AT BETTER SMOKE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM FOR
PRESCRIBED FIRES.
INCLUDING AIR MONITORING AND
INCREASE PUBLIC OUTREACH WE'RE
REQUESTING FUNDING OF THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE FIRST YEAR AND THEN ONGOING
FUNDING OF TWO POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS.
ON AIR DISTRICTS ARE THE ONES
WHO ACTUALLY MAKE THE ON THE
GROUND DECISIONS ABOUT WHICH
BURNS ARE AUTHORIZED TO THIS
REQUEST INCLUDES TWO MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR THE AIR DISTRICTS
TO FULLY ENGAGE AND BOTH THE AIR
MONITORING AND PRESCRIBED FIRE
APPROVAL PROCESS.
ON THIS REQUEST IS BUILT ON A
PILOT PROGRAM THAT CARP THE AIR
DISTRICTS AND CAL FIRE WORKED ON
OVER THE LAST YEAR.
THIS PROGRAM MONITORED SMOKE
FROM PURSE FOR ACTUALLY INCREASE
THE DAYS AN ACREAGE IS A
PRESCRIBED FIRES WHILE
MINIMIZING IMPACTS TO PUBLIC
HEALTH.
THIS PILOT WAS SUCCESSFUL AND
THESE REQUESTED RESOURCES WILL
SUPPORT AIR MONITORING FOR MORE
PRESCRIBED FIRES HELPING US
INCREASE STAYS IN ANCHORAGES.
IT WILL ALSO HELP US INFORM DOWN
WHEN COMMUNITIES ABOUT POTENTIAL
HEALTH IMPACTS AND DEVELOP MORE
ACCURATE SMOKE MODELING.
ON THIS IMPROVE SMOKE MODELING
HELPS US REFINE THE INFORMATION
THAT WE PROVIDE IN AN ONLINE
TOOL CALLED P. FURS.
AND WHAT THIS TOOL DOES IS IT
HELP STREAMLINE THE PRESCRIBED
FIRE APPROVAL AND REPORTING
PROCESS.
I'M FINALLY THE REQUESTED
RESOURCES WILL ENABLE US TO
EXPAND OUR PUBLIC OUTREACH
EFFORTS AND TO COORDINATE COMMON
PUBLIC MESSAGING WITH OTHER
AGENCIES.
ALSO DEALING WITH SMOKE
MANAGEMENT SO THANK YOU AND I'D
BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
SB NINE OH ONE REQUIREMENTS --
AT THAT ARE THAT WE CAN GET A B.
C. P. -- FOR
THE X..
THAT THAT WOULD THAT WOULD BE
THE CONFINED THAT GREENHOUSE GAS
IMPACTS OF FORCE THAN AND AND
ESTABLISHING A BASELINE OF
HISTORIC FIRE MISSIONS IN
CALIFORNIA.
IS THERE A REASON FOR THAT.
GOOD MORNING Là VERY DEPARTMENT
FINANCE I'M WE BELIEVE THAT
AIRPORT HAS ROBUST EMISSIONS BY
TRACKING QUANTIFICATION SYSTEMS
ALREADY IN PLACE SO WE DID NOT
PUT FORWARD A REQUEST.
FOR SB NINE A ONE AND EMISSIONS
BASELINE ESTABLISHMENT SO THAT
FUNCTION THOSE FUNCTIONS ARE
OBSERVABLE WITH AND CURRENT
FUNDING.
GREAT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
DID YOU WANT ADDED DID YOU.
DID YOU WANT TO ADD A COMMENT.
SELECT DELL COMPUTERS AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE SO
I'M NOT SPECIFICALLY ON THE AIR
BE PROPOSAL BUT BROADLY ACROSS
ALL OF THE PROPOSALS TO
IMPLEMENT THE LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE.
I AM OUR REVIEW NOTES THAT THE
PROPOSAL'S ARE GENERALLY
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT IS REQUIRED
IN THE LEGISLATION AND WERE SEEN
WORKLOAD INCREASES THE STAFFING
INCREASES SEEMED A REASONABLE
AND AND AND GENERALLY
APPROPRIATE.
AND BUT THIS IS ONE AREA THAT WE
THINK AND REALLY IT MERITS A LOT
AS ADDITIONAL LEGISLATIVE
ATTENTION AND LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT --
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
SPECIFIC PROPOSALS HERE A LOT OF
THE QUESTIONS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
ASKED AND BY THE COMMITTEE
ALREADY BUT?
AND THAT THE LEGISLATURE GAVE A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF
FLEXIBILITY AND DISCRETION TO
THE MINISTRATION TO IMPLEMENT
THE LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE.
WHAT LEGISLATION IS NEVER SUPER
JUST WINE AND TO RECOMMEND THAT
YOU WOULD MAKE SURE THAT THE THE
THE WAY THAT THESE SPECIFIC
COMPONENTS ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED
IN THE BUDGET YEAR IS REALLY
CONSISTENT WITH LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES?
I'M AND THERE'S A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS AND SOME OF THEM ARE
ARE OUTLINED IN EITHER A GENDO
THERE'S A COUPLE THAT HAVEN'T
BEEN TOUCHED ON YET SO JUST
HIGHLIGHT THOSE FOR YOU.
AND RELATED TO CAL FIRE THE AND
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT THE
TURNER MILLION DOLLARS WAS
TOUCHED ON SOMEONE AND WITH
RESPECT TO THE GRANTS AND
THERE'S ALSO THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A DEDICATED
PRESCRIBED BURN CREW IS --
THAT'S A NEW FUNCTION IS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S IN THE PROCESS I'VE
IN THE CURRENT YEAR HIRING AND
STAFFING AT THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
DETAIL ABOUT WHERE THESE CREWS
ARE GONNA BE LOCATED WHAT ARE
THE CHALLENGES IN.
HIRING STAFF AND GETTING THEM
TRAINED ON AND HOW AND HOW FAIRS
GOING TO PRIORITIZE THAT
WORKLOAD A WEIRD IT DIDN'T
DEPLOY THESE CREWS.
AND AND HOW THAT IS GOING TO
INTERACT AND IN A IN A WAY THAT
IT'S AND COMPLEMENTARY TO THE
GRANTS AND THE OTHER THINGS THAT
AND THAT CALAVERAS DOING.
M. AND SO WE THINK THERE'S JUST
MORE INFORMATION THAT YOU MIGHT
WANT THEIR ABOUT AND WHERE WHERE
THEY'RE AT IN THE CURRENT YEAR
AND THEN AS THEY EXPAND TO THE
CRUISE WHAT LESSONS HAVE THEY
LEARNED FROM THE PROCESS OF
HIRING UP THE INITIAL SIX CREWS.
HOW IS THAT GOING TO CHANGE
THINGS AS THEY EXPAND TO TEN
PRESCRIBED BURN CREWS HOW ARE
THEY GOING TO ENSURE THAT THESE
CREWS ARE REALLY FOCUSED ON
PRESCRIBED BURN WORK AND NOT
GETTING PULLED TO RESPOND TO
EMERGENCIES AND THINGS LIKE THAT?
AND THE OTHER PIECE THAT HASN'T
REALLY BEEN TOUCHED ON YET --
RELATIVE TO THESE THESE BUDGET
PROPOSALS.
IS I'M SB NINE A ONE REQUIRES
CAL FIRE TO DEVELOP THE WIRE
WILDFIRE RESILIENCE PROGRAM THIS
PROGRAM IS INTENDED TO PROVIDE
AND THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
SUPPORT TO LANDOWNERS TO HELP
THEM.
SORT OF NAVIGATE THROUGH THE
REGULATORY PROCESS AND THERE'S
SOME FUNDING AND PROPOSED.
IN IN THE BUDGET RELATED TO THIS
WILDFIRE RESILIENCE PROGRAM AND
YOU MIGHT WANT MORE INFORMATION
ON WHY THIS IS THE RIGHT SIZE
FOR THAT PROGRAM HOW MANY
LANDOWNERS THEY EXPECT TO BE
ABLE TO HELP.
WITH THE FUNDING AND STAFFING
THAT'S BEEN PROPOSED AND JUST
ENSURE THAT THAT REALLY ALIGNS
WITH WHAT THE LEGISLATURE --
INTENDED WHEN WHEN THE
LEGISLATION WAS PASSED REQUIRING
THEM TO CREATE THIS PROGRAM.
WE THINK THERE'S ALSO AN NUMBER
AS I'M OVERSIGHT QUESTIONS FOR
THE LONGER TERM BEYOND JUST
WHAT'S IN THE BUDGET.
FOR NINETEEN TWENTY AND THAT.
REALLY THE OUTCOMES THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT HERE FOR IMPROVING
FOREST HEALTH AND AND PREVENTING
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
AND WE'RE GOING TO BE DIFFICULT
TO MEASURE AND IT'S GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
WANT TO THINK ABOUT OVER THE
LONGER TERM AND SO.
MAKING SURE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS COLLECTING
DATA IN A WAY AND MEASURING
OUTCOMES IN A WAY THAT REALLY
GETS THE LEGISLATURE THE
INFORMATION IT NEEDS TO
UNDERSTAND AND THAT THE PROGRAMS
ARE BEING SUCCESSFUL AND MEETING
THEIR GOALS.
AND WE THINK THAT THERE'S
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT QUESTIONS
RELATED TO AND HOW FUNDS ARE
BEING ALLOCATED TO THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY AREAS ASSEMBLY WOMAN
RAY AS YOU KIND OF TOUCHED ON
THIS ALREADY WITH THAT. HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE MILLION AND AND YOU
CHAIR --
WHAT ARE THE LESSONS BEING
LEARNED AND AND HOW IS CAL FIRE?
REALLY ENSURING THAT IT'S IT'S
NOT JUST GRANTING OUT FUNDS TO
THE HIGHEST POVERTY PROJECTS TO
GETS APPLICATIONS FOR BUT IS IT
BEING PROACTIVE IN TERMS OF
IDENTIFYING.
THE AREAS OF THE GREATEST NEED --
ON THIS TOPIC I WOULD KNOW YOUR
STAFF AGENDA ALSO --
POINTS OUT THE COMMUNITY WHILE
FIRE PREVENTION MITIGATION
REPORT THAT WAS JUST RELEASED BY
THE ADMINISTRATION THIS IS WHAT
THEY'RE REFERRING TO IS THE
FORTY FIVE DAY PLAN --
AND THAT SETS OUT SOME
PRIORITIES --
OF FOR WORK THAT CAN BE DONE IN
THE IN THE IN THE IMMEDIATE TERM
AND THE NEAR TERM. TO REDUCE
FUELS AND PROTECT CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES AT RISK AND YOUR
STAFF AGENDA IT PROPERLY SORT OF
ASK THE QUESTION OF WHAT HOW IS
THIS GOING TO BE FUNDED IS THIS
COMING OUT OF EXISTING FINDS HOW
DOES THIS RELATE TO THE MONEY
THAT'S BEING PROPOSED --
FOR NINETEEN TWENTY AND THAT THE
FOREST HEALTH AND FIRE
PREVENTION GRANTS SO THOSE ARE A
LOT OF GOOD OVERSIGHT QUESTIONS
AND AND WE WE LAY OUT IN OUR OUR
REVIEW OF THE BUDGET PROPOSALS
ADDITIONAL ON GOING OVERSIGHT%
QUESTIONS.
BARRIERS TO IMPLEMENTING IS THE
APPROPRIATE WORK FORCE AVAILABLE
TO BE ABLE.
TO AND THAT THAT YOU KNOW I FOR
WERE WERE MAKING HEALTH WORKERS
FEELS REDUCTION ARE THEY
STRUGGLING TO HIRE PEOPLE TO
ACTUALLY DO THE WORK --
AND SO ARE THEIR VERY YEARS WORK
FORCE CARRIERS AND OTHER THINGS
LIKE THAT AND SO WE LAY OUT A
LIST OF QUESTIONS WE DO THINK
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO WANT TO
MAKE SURE FOR BOTH.
THE SPECIFIC PROPOSALS FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR AS WELL AS ON GOING
THAT THIS IS AN AREA THAT --
WOULD REALLY BENEFIT FROM A LOT
OF LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR THE COMPREHENSIVE --
A REPORT YES IF YOU WANT TO ADD.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN BLOOMERS
JULIANNA MOORE IS A ME WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I JUST
WANTED TO ADD A NOTE.
AS FAR AS A ARBY'S FUNDING TO TO
BRING TO YOUR ATTENTION THAT
CURRENT YEAR.
THEY DO THEY DID RECEIVE --
THROUGH AN AGREEMENT WITH CAL
FIRE FIVE POINT FIVE MILLION. TO
BEGIN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
INCREASE PRESCRIBED FIRE BURNING --
AND I SAW THE GRAND FOR P..
FOR I WOULD SAY YES FOR THE
THANK YOU I WAS PRESCRIBED.
MYERS WHAT.
IN A IN A IN A TOWN THAT'S A
FILLED WITH ACRONYMS I LIKE TO
KNOW WHAT THEY MEAN YEAH.
THAT THAT MEANS PRESCRIBED FIRE
INFORMATION REPORTING SYSTEM SO.
IN THE PAST IT IT'S BEEN
AVAILABLE.
BUT ON A VOLUNTARY BASIS AND NOT
EVERYBODY HAS BEEN NOT ALL OF
THE LOCALS.
HAVE BEEN USING IT.
BUT SINCE THE FOCUS.
IS MORE ON THE WILD FIRES AND
PREVENTION.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT MORE WHICH
YOU.
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG BUT
THERE'S A LOT MORE --
INTENT TO PARTICIPATE IN IT.
AND FOR EXAMPLE THAT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THE CURRENT YEAR
BUDGET.
IS STRENGTHENING.
SO THEY DO HAVE RESOURCES TO
PERFORM SOME OF THE WORK THAT SB
NINE A ONE IS IS LAYING OUT.
IN THE CURRENT YEAR RESOURCES AS
WELL AS SB NINE A ONE BASICALLY
FOR A ARBY'S PURPOSES.
JUST.
MOVED FORWARD WHAT WE'RE DOING
WHAT THEY'RE DOING CURRENTLY.
WOULD YOU.
SO THE TICKET TO THE PAPER'S
QUESTION I WAS GOING TO SPARE
YOU WHAT THE ACRONYM ACTUALLY
FRIENDS BECAUSE I HAD TO LOOK UP
WHAT IT MEANT I'M WHEN I WAS
PREPARING FOR THE TESTIMONY.
IT IS IT HOW IT IS A VOLUNTARY
SYSTEM BUT IT IS THE WAY THAT WE
HELP MANAGE MAKING OF BURN CALLS.
UP BOARDS THE FOR BOTH THE FOR
SERVICE AND CAL FIRE ARE BOTH
USING P. FIRST FOR ALL OF THEIR
PRESCRIBED FIRES NOW AND WITH
THE COMING INCREASING PRESCRIBED
FIRES WERE EXPECTING TO SEE.
EVEN MORE ACTIVITY IN THAT
SYSTEM SO THERE'S FUNDING IN
THIS REQUEST TO HELP SORT OF
BOLSTER IT'S KIND OF ONE OF
THOSE AGING SYSTEMS --
AND THEN ALSO AS I MENTIONED
HAVING SOME MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT SMOKE MODELING HELPS US BE
ABLE TO USE P. FIRST MORE
AFFECTIVELY SO THE DISTRICTS
WHEN THEY LOOK AT THE DATA CAN
SEE -- THIS
IS THESE BURNS HAVEN'T EVEN
HAPPENS THIS IS WHERE WE THINK
THE SMOKE WOULD GO AND THAT WILL
HELP US WITH OUR PUBLIC OUTREACH
AS WELL.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
EXPLANATION IS A LITTLE BIT
HUMOROUS SO YOU KNOW.
PLEASE YOU TO MAYBE NOT TAKE IT
AS SERIOUSLY AS SOME OTHERS --
BUT I APPRECIATE THE YOUR
ELUCIDATING THE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT'S IT'S GOOD
THAT -- THAT
YOU'RE IN THAT POSITION --
SO AGAIN WE'RE HOLDING THIS ITEM
OPEN BUT A LOT OF THOSE
QUESTIONS MISS PETERS THAT --
AND AND POINTS THAT YOU WERE
MAKING ARE THE THINGS THAT --
I THINK OUR STAFF REALLY BECAUSE
THIS IS --
UP PRETTY OVERWHELMING AMOUNT OF
WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE AND
AMOUNT OF AND IN TURN THE
OVERSIGHT THAT WE DO --
WE'RE GOING TO NEED THAT
ADDITIONAL TIMES STAFF GONNA
NEED THAT ADDITIONAL TIME
BETWEEN NOW AND OUR NEXT.
TO A HEARING AFTER THE MAY
REVISED --
THAT TO REVIEW ALL THOSE POINTS
SOUND RECOMMENDATION TO US SO
WILL BE -- A
HEARING THIS ITEM AGAIN BUT WE
DO WANT TO TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THIS ITEM SO WHEN WE MOVED TO
THAT RIGHT NOW.
OKAY YEAH YEAH AFTER PUBLIC
COMMENT AS PEOPLE ARE STEPPING
FORWARD WILL --
I WILL ALLOW --
MEMBERS WERE ABSENT FOR VOTES TO
CATCH UP.
YOUR SINGLE BECKY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
WE'RE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE B.
C. P. FOR THE FIFTEEN POSITIONS
FOR FISH AND WILDLIFE TWELVE OF
WHICH WOULD BE --
USED AT THE TIME A REGULATION
ENFORCED RESTORATION FUND JUST
TO GIVE THE COMMITTEE A LITTLE
BIT OF BACKGROUND ABOUT THE
TIMBER REGULATION ENFORCED
RESTORATION FUND.
IS A SPECIAL FUND THAT WAS
CREATED IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB --
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO WHICH THE
INDUSTRY SUPPORTED AND IT
CREATED A 1% ASSESSMENT ON
LUMBER SALES AT THE POINT OF
PURCHASE AND THE POINT OF THAT
FUND -- OF
WHICH TWO MILLION DOLLARS
THEY'RE SEEKING TO HAVE FUNDED
FOR THE TWELVE POSITIONS.
OF THE FIFTEEN IS THAT THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE IT ENSURE THAT
THERE WAS ENOUGH STAFF AVAILABLE
TO DO A THOROUGH AND ACCURATE
REVIEW.
OF THE TIMBER HARVEST PLANS AND
PLANS ASSOCIATED WITH TO THAT
THOUGH THERE WERE SUPPOSED TO
ACHIEVE EFFICIENCIES --
UNDER THIS PROGRAM BECAUSE THEY
WERE GOING TO BE RECEIVING THIS
INCREASE IN STAFF AND SO AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATTERSON.
RAISE SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
ABOUT THIS --
TWENTY SEVENTEEN REPORT THAT
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY UNDER
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO IS REQUIRED
TO SUBMIT EVERY YEAR BY JANUARY
TENTH OF EACH YEAR --
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AS THE LAST
REPORT WE SEEN IN THAT USES
FIGURES FROM FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN
SO IT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL IF
YOU'RE TRYING TO HAVE FIFTEEN
POSITIONS TWELVE WHICH ARE
FUNDED OUT OF THIS FUND.
AND WE'RE SUPPOSED TO ACHIEVE
EFFICIENCIES AND A LAST REPORT
WE SEEN IS FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN
USING FIFTEEN SIXTEEN NUMBERS.
IF WE COULD SEE A TREND THAT IS
IMPROVING OVER WITH THE REPORT
FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHICH AS
THEY POINTED OUT WE SEE AN
INCREASE OF OVER TWENTY P. Y.
FROM THAT PARTICULAR YEAR.
A DECREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
SUBMISSIONS OF T. H. PEAS AND
ANCHORS TREATED AND YET REVIEW
TIME WENT UP ON AVERAGE TWENTY
TWENTY DAYS PER ROOM PER TEACH
P..
SO WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE THE
EFFICIENCIES THAT WERE THAT WERE.
UNDER FOURTEEN NINETY TWO THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT --
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO SEE THE
EIGHTEEN IN NINETEEN REPORT SO
WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
TRENDS ARE BEING CORRECTED --
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO SEE AN
ORGANIZATION CHART FROM FISH AND
WILDLIFE SO WE CAN ENSURE THAT
THOSE FOLKS THAT ARE WORKING --
ON FOURTEEN NINETY TWO ARE ONLY
SINCE IT IS A SPECIAL FUND --
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
OVERALL HEALTH OF THAT FUNDS --
THE ON AVERAGE I THINK EVEN IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY WERE
PROPOSING TO SPEND --
FIVE OR SIX MILLION DOLLARS MORE
THAN WE HAVE COMING IN AND
REVENUES --
SO IF THAT TREND WILL CONTINUE
OUR CONCERN IS THAT THE
FOLLOWING YEAR WE ACTUALLY MIGHT
BE AT OR BELOW THAT FOUR MILLION
DOLLAR MARK.
EVEN MORE CONCERNING THEN THAT
IS THE FACT THAT MOST OF THAT
MONEY IS BEING SPENT ON STAFF
WHICH IS A LONGER GOING --
PROCESS AND CONTINUING PROCESS.
AS OPPOSED TO SPENDING DOWN A
RESERVE ON ONE TIME GRANTS --
FINALLY WERE CONCERNED THAT IN
THE JUSTIFICATION OF THE B. C.
P. IT SAYS THAT SB NINE OH ONE
REQUIRES FISH AND WILDLIFE TO
REVIEW THESE EXEMPTIONS.
AND AS AS WE'VE CLARIFIED TODAY
THESE EXEMPTIONS ARE MINISTERIAL
THEY DON'T REQUIRE THE REVIEW OR
APPROVAL --
IN FACT SB NINE A ONE REQUIRES --
CAL FIRE TO RECEIVE THE
MINISTERIAL DOCUMENT THEY IN
TURN SEND IT OUT TO THE
REMAINING DEPARTMENTS --
UNLESS OF A CAL FIRE IS THE ONE
THAT DETERMINES IF THE DOCUMENTS
ARE ACCURATE AND COMPLETE --
BUT IT IS MINISTERIAL AND DOES
NOT REQUIRE THEIR APPROVAL --
IF FISH AND WILDLIFE WAS LOOKING
AT INCREASING THE MONITORING --
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE EXEMPTIONS
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN AND
CONSIDERING HOWEVER.
AGAIN --
WHEN TALKING ABOUT THE WE LOOKED
AT TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO TRY AND
GET A BASELINE OF HOW MUCH WORK
THESE DEPARTMENTS OF THESE
REGIONS ALREADY HAD CONSIDERING
THEY WERE LOOKING AT HIRING TO
NEW FULL TIME POSITION?
TO NEW POSITIONS FOR THIS IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BETWEEN THOSE
TWO REGIONS THEY HAD A TOTAL OF
ONE EXEMPTION. ONE LESS THAN
THREE ACRE CONVERSION AND ZERO
TIMBER HARVEST PLANTS AND SO FOR
US IF THEY WERE LOOKING AT AREAS
THE REGIONS THAT HAVE THE MOST --
ACTIVITY IN OUR INDUSTRY AND
WANTED TO HIRE ADDITIONAL ONE
PERSON FOR EACH OF THOSE REGIONS
THAT WOULD MAKE MORE SENSE TO US --
BUT THOSE ARE THOSE CONCERNS
THAT WE HAVE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN BLOOM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE PAUL
MASON FOR THE OPPOSITE FOR
STRESSED WANTED DRYER ATTENTION
TO THIS LETTER THAT WE DELIVERED
LAST WEEK FROM PACIFIC FOREST
TRUST THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE CALIFORNIA
PLANS TO CITING HALF OF THE
DOZEN OTHER NGOS.
AND ALL LARGELY BE TRACKING
ALONG THOSE SAME ISSUES --
THOSE A VERY DENSE HEARING THIS
MORNING A LOT OF INFORMATION I
WILL TRY AND SPEAK TO ALL THE
THINGS THAT WE SUPPORT BUT
RATHER.
FLY SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE
THINK.
DESERVE A LITTLE MORE ATTENTION.
I WILL NOTE THAT WHERE ARE MY
ORGANIZATION FRANKLY ALL THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS --
BEING APPROPRIATE FOR THE MORE
SALT AND FIRE PREVENTION
PROGRAMS AND TO BE USED IN THE
WAY THAT IT WAS USED IN THE PAST
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
THAT WE MAINTAIN SOME STABILITY
AND HOW ARE USING CAN BUILD WORK
FORCES AND BUSINESSES THAT ARE
ACTUALLY EXECUTING THIS WORKING
NOT.
WAITING AROUND HERE TO YEAR --
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE THE
CPUS FROM DFW AND THE WATER
BOARD TO MONITOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE THE
VARIOUS VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
ACTIVITIES AND THAT'S BEEN ON A
ONE OR SOMETHING THAT WE ASK.
FOR IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS.
I WILL FLAG I THINK THAT IT'S
ALSO IN A GOOD OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO NOT JUST BE LOOKING AT THE
ACTIVITIES THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN PROPOSED ARE HAPPENING BUT
BE MORE PROACTIVE AND USE THIS
AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO DRAW.
THE DIFFERENT MANAGEMENT --
AGENCIES ARE REVIEW TEAM
AGENCIES TOGETHER TO PROACTIVELY
LOOK AT WATERSHEDS IDENTIFY
THOSE AREAS THAT ARE THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY --
SO THEY WERE TARGETING THOSE AND
REALLY TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
BROADER WATERSHED HEALTH GOALS
AS PART OF THESE ACTIVITIES AND
NOT BEING ENTIRELY.
REACTIVE AND JUST LOOKING AT
THINGS AFTER THE FACT SO I THINK
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
COMMITTEE.
TO PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
GUIDANCE TO THOSE BCP'S.
AND I WANT TO FOCUS IN ON WHAT I
THINK ARE THE TWO BIGGEST
CONCERNS AND I APPRECIATE THE
CHAIR RAISING THESE --
WITH REGARDS TO THOSE TWO
PROVISIONS THAT DIRECT THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. TO DO
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE GONNA BE
ABSOLUTELY FOUNDATIONAL TO THE
SUCCESS OF THIS BROADER PROGRAM.
IF YOU TALK TO ANYBODY WHO HAS
BEEN INVOLVED IN THE YOU KNOW
VARIOUS FUELS REDUCTION
ACTIVITIES OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS THEY WILL UNDOUBTEDLY
COMPLAIN ABOUT THE
QUANTIFICATION METHODOLOGIES.
FOR HOW WE GO ABOUT DOING THAT
IT HAS BEEN THERE'S THERE'S ROOM
FOR IMPROVEMENT THERE.
AND THERE'S THAT OR A LESS RIGHT
WAY TO DO THAT ARE YOU KNOW.
IF AIR WE DOESN'T HAVE RESOURCES
TO DO THAT WELL WE'RE NOT GOING
TO END UP WITH A GOOD SYSTEM WE
MIGHT END UP WITH A SYSTEM BUT
IT WON'T BE THE SYSTEM THAT
WOULD REALLY HELP US FACILITATE.
THE TYPE OF THE SCALE OF WORK
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AND HAVING
TO INTEGRATE WELL INTO THE REST
OF OUR ACCOUNTING WORK THE A. R.
B. AS ALREADY DOING AND DOING SO
WELL.
I THINK IT'S REALLY WILL BE
PENNY WISE AND POUND FOOLISH TO
NOT PROVIDE THEM WITH SOME
RESOURCES TO DO A GOOD JOB --
STREAMLINING THE QUANTIFICATION
METHODS FOR THE FUEL REDUCTION
ACTIVITIES.
THE OTHER IS ESTABLISHING A
CREDIBLE BASELINE FOR WHAT SORT
OF EMISSIONS LOSING FROM FIRE IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORICALLY.
THAT PUTS ALL OF WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IN CONTEXT ABSENT
HAVING THAT INFORMATION IN A
GOOD RELIABLE SCIENTIFICALLY
CREDIBLE WAY WE'RE JUST SORT OF
FLAILING AROUND THE DARKENED LE
THESE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF YOU KNOW.
WHAT SORT OF FIRE MISSIONS WE'RE
SEEING RIGHT NOW?
AS WE'RE MOVING FORWARD --
WITH THE STATE'S GOAL OF
ESTABLISHING --
CARBON THE TRIAL A PATH TO
CARBON THE TROLLEY BY.
TWENTY FORTY FIVE HAVING SOME
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THAT.
BASELINE OF EMISSIONS IS UNDER
SORT OF AN ECOLOGICALLY STABLE
CONDITION IN CALIFORNIA BEFORE
WE AND FIRE SUPPRESSION AND ALL
THAT AMENDMENT ACTIVITIES.
THAT'S AN INTEGRAL PART OF THAT --
THE PENNY WISE AND POUND FOOLISH
TO NOT MAKE SURE WE'RE DOING
THAT PART WELL AND WITH THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
BRING INTO IT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION THAT'S THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICERS FROM ALL
THIRTY FIVE LOCAL THEIR
DISTRICTS.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING AT
COOPERATIVELY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
ON IMPLEMENTATION OF THE STATE'S
AT PRESCRIBED.
FIRE PLANS AND AND FORCED ERROR --
GOALS AND FORESTRY GOALS --
WERE SUPPORTIVE OF THE BCP TO
PROVIDE FUNDING TO THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD AND ALSO --
IN TURN THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS --
TO ENGAGE IN --
INCREASE PRESCRIBED FIRE
ACTIVITIES IN OUR REGION SO WE
WE'RE JEER AT ADOPTION OF THAT
THANK YOU.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AT
LUCAS FACTS ABOUT THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY OF COURSE SUPPORTS
THE OVERALL --
LEGISLATIVE --
WILDFIRE RECOVERY IN AT
PREVENTION BCP BUT WE ALSO WANT
TO JUST HIGHLIGHT A FEW SPECIFIC
ITEMS SPECIFICALLY THAT TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS SUPPOSED
TO BE SPENT AND THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET.
FROM DRF --
FOR FORCED HEALTH AND THERE
CONSISTENT WITH SB NOT A ONE I
THINK THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT THE
PACE AND SCALE OF ECOLOGICALLY.
BASED FORCE MANAGEMENT NEEDS TO
BE SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED --
IN PARTICULAR GIVEN THE
MAGNITUDE AND URGENCY OF THE
PROBLEM.
IN ADDITION WE ARE ALSO
SUPPORTIVE OF CALPERS REQUEST
FOR TWO POINT FIVE MILLION TO
INCREASE THE STATE OF USE THAT
STATE THE USE EXCUSE ME
PRESCRIBED FIRE.
THAT MEET THEIR GOALS OF SB AT
TWELVE SIXTY AND THEN LASTLY
JUST WOULD SAY WE REALLY
APPRECIATE --
THE EFFORTS AND WORK OF CHIEF
PORTER AND HOW HIS STAFF CAL
FIRE AND HELPING PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
I'M MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRISTMAS KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF
HUMBLED REDWOOD COMPANY
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANY AND MY
CLIENTS AS WELL AS THE TIMBER
INDUSTRY AND MYSELF FOR THAT
MATTER WERE.
HEAVILY INVOLVED IN THE ADOPTION
OF THE BILL PREVIOUSLY
REFERENCED A. B..
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO IN TWENTY
TWELVE WE SHARE THE CONCERNS
THAT THE SEAT CALIFORNIA'S
ASSOCIATION RAISED --
WOULD LIKE TO DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION IN PARTICULAR. TO TO
PROVISIONS IN AB FOURTEEN NINETY
TWO AND THE SPEAKS MORE BROADLY
THAN JUST THE DFW.
OUR REQUEST AND WE DO CONCUR
WITH THE QUESTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISING YOUR STAFF ANALYSIS
DRAWING SOME AT LEAST QUESTION --
TO THAT FUNDAMENTALLY WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT YOU HAVE ADEQUATE
RESOURCES IN FRONT OF YOU TO
EVALUATE PROPERLY EVALUATE.
THIS AND THE OTHER RELATED
REQUEST DUE TO LACK OF HAVING
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN REPORTS IN FRONT OF YOU
AS WELL AS FOR THE PRIVATE.
REGULATED SECTOR TO BE AWARE.
BUT FUNDAMENTALLY MY CLIENT
WANTS TO EXPRESS CONCERN WITH
THE FAILURE --
TO CREATE THOSE PROVISIONS TO
ACHIEVE EFFICIENCIES WE HAVE
BEEN ANXIOUSLY WAITING SINCE.
TWENTY THIRTEEN WHEN THE AGENCY
IN THE DEPARTMENTS BEGAN LOOKING
AT THAT.
AND I WOULD DRAW YOUR ATTENTION
SPECIFICALLY TO THE STATUTE IN
PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE IF I MAY
MISTER CHAIR. FOR SIX TO NINE
POINT TWO AND JUST NOTE TO
PROVISIONS IF I COULD
SUBDIVISION F. WHICH SAYS TO
PROMOTE TRANSPARENCY IN
REGULATORY COSTS IN PROGRAMS
THROUGH THE CREATION.
OF PERFORMANCE MEASURES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE STATE'S
FOREST PRACTICE REGULATORY
PROGRAM AND SIMPLIFY THE
COLLECTION AND USE OF CRITICAL
DATA TO ENSURE CONSISTENCY WITH
OTHER PERTINENT LAWS AND
REGULATIONS.
AND ONE QUICK SENTENCE FROM
SUBDIVISION G. THE CALLS UPON
THESE ENTITIES TO IDENTIFY AND
IMPLEMENT EFFICIENCIES IN THE
REGULATION OF TIMBER HARVESTING
BETWEEN THE STATE AGENCIES.
THAT HAS YET TO OCCUR IN THE
HALF A DOZEN PLUS YEARS THAT HE
BE FOURTEEN NINETY TWO HAS BEEN
ON THE BOOKS THANK YOU.
JOSH DUGGAR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT OF FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT
THE WILDFIRE LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE
THESE ARE IMPORTANT ISSUES FOR
COUNTIES AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT THIS CRITICAL AREA.
GOOD MORNING MR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON FEDERAL OF ON THE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PLAN
CITING NOT ABOUT CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD LIKE TO START BY A GOING
IN A LINE IN THE COMMENTS FROM
MISTER MASON FROM PACIFIC FOR
STRESSED.
OVER BOTH OF THOSE ORGANIZATIONS --
AS WELL AS JUST PUT A FINER
POINT ON A COUPLE NOTING IN IN A
SETTING LIKE THIS.
THE FIRST ONE IS THAT YOU KNOW
GENERALLY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
FORCE MANAGEMENT --
AND FORCED HEALTH INTERVENTIONS
WITH THAT'S FOR STUNNING AT
CENTER --
IT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT TO
DISTINGUISH THE THE BENEFITS
THAT WERE GOING AFTER THEIR FROM
AN ECOLOGICAL STANDPOINT AND AND
THE POTENTIAL BENEFITS THAT MAY
OR MAY NOT EXIST --
FOR PREVENTING THE KIND OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES ALWAYS UP
IN PARADISE WHERE THERE YOU KNOW
WE SAW -- A
NEED FOR FOR HOME HARDENING
AGAINST MEMBERS --
IS REALLY A CRITICAL PIECE TO TO
ENSURING THAT WERE ABLE TO AVOID
SOME OF THESE --
CATASTROPHES IN THE FUTURE --
AND NOT TO COMPLETE THE TO
NECESSARILY AS BEING AS ONE
BEING THE SOLUTION FOR THE OTHER
THAT THEY'RE BOTH VERY IMPORTANT
WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF BOTH --
BUT I THINK ULTIMATELY --
WE WOULDN'T WANT TO PUT
OURSELVES IN A POSITION WHERE
WE'RE MAKING THE CLAIM THAT BY
DOING THESE FORCED HEALTH
MANAGEMENT VENGEANCE ALONE WE
WILL BEEN PREVENT --
SOME OF THESE CATASTROPHIC
EVENTS THAT ARE HAPPENING IN IN
OUR COMMUNITIES --
BUT BUT I THINK THAT YOU KNOW
THAT THAT HOPEFULLY IS IS
SOMETHING THAT --
MOST FOLKS AND IN THIS ROOM CAN
AGREE RELATES TO THE DATA
DEVELOPING THE BASS LINES THAT
AND THAT MISTER MASON --
SPOKE ON THAT THERE'S ALSO A
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL DATA --
WE HAVE TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO US NOW INCLUDING
LIGHTER WE'VE BEEN HAVING SOME
DISCUSSIONS NOW WITH DEPARTMENTS
AND AGENCIES ABOUT THE THE
ABILITY TO THAN YOU REALIZE THAT
DATA ACROSS MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS
IT'S IT'S VERY --
IT'S THE KIND OF INFORMATION
THAT ALLOWS FOR CROSS
POLLINATION OF IDEAS RIGHT.
BENEFITS FROM FOR A RB FOR FOR
THEIR ACCOUNTING METHODOLOGIES
FOR UNDERSTANDING HOW MUCH
CARBON STOCK IS OUT THERE AND
WHAT IS OUT THERE RIGHT NOW --
BENEFITS TO THE WATER BOARD FOR
ALL THE WATERSHED IMPACTS --
THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
AS WELL AS THE F. W. FOR
ENSURING THE THE CONTINUANCE OF
OUR ON A PROTECTION OF OUR
PUBLIC TRUST --
NATURAL RESOURCES --
THEN FINALLY WANT TO MENTION --
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY IS
SUPPORTIVE OF OF SMALL SCALE
BIOMASS --
AS AN INTERVENTION IN TOOL IN
DEALING WITH --
ALL FUELS REDUCTION THE NEEDS TO
HAPPEN IN IN OUR IN OUR FOREST
LANDS -- BUT
ALSO WANTED TO PUT A FINE POINT
AND SAY THATWE ALSO DON'T WANT
THAT TO BE --
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SMALL
SCALE THREE FIVE MEGABYTES --
FOR FOR THE FACILITIES BUT WE
ALSO DON'T WANT AND ESPECIALLY
TO COMMUNITIES IN THAT ARE
ALREADY OVER BURDENED --
FROM INNER POLLUTION STANDPOINT
IN BASINS THAT THAT SIMPLY
CANNOT AFFORD ADDITIONAL --
PARTICULAR MATTER IN THEIR OWN
SO WITH THAT YOU KNOW WANTING.
TO BE SUPPORT OF A DISCUSSION A
LOOKS AT BEST AVAILABLE CONTROL
TECHNOLOGIES AND THE CITING OF
THESE FACILITIES IN PLACES THAT
THAT DON'T ADD TO THAT BURDEN
FOR THE COMMUNITIES THAT CAN
LEAST AFFORD IT ESPECIALLY IN
CENTRAL VALLEY --
SO WITH THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE TIME --
THANKS CAN.
YOU'RE WELCOME THAT --
BRINGS THIS ITEM TO A CLOSE AND
LET'S CATCH UP ON VOTES.
THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS ONE THROUGH.
SEVEN THE CURRENT VOTE FOUR ZERO
CHAIR VOTING HI.
GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
VOTE ONLY ISSUES EIGHT AND NINE
CURRENT VOTE FOUR ZERO CHAIR
VOTING I GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
ITEMS TO BE HEARD ISSUE NUMBER
TEN CURRENT VOTE FOUR ZERO CHAIR
VOTING AYE GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
GREAT SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO UNDER ITEMS TO
BE HEARD THAT'S THE ENHANCE FIRE
PROTECTION RESOURCES.
THE IT IS EMPTY THIS PLACE OUT
[inaudible]
WELCOME BACK.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN CHAIRMAN
BLOOM -- TOM
PORTER CAL FIRE --
AND ARE WE GOING TO TAKE THIS ME
FIRST.
I THINK IT WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR
THE CHIEF TO PRESENT THE ISSUE
TO YOU ALL.
AND WILL AT OUR COMMENTS AS
APPROPRIATE.
ALL RIGHT --
SO ISSUE NUMBER TWO IS ENHANCED
FIRE PART --
FIRE PROTECTION RESOURCES --
AGAIN THIS IS --
CAL FIRE AND THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS --
REQUESTING --
NINETY FIVE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND WHICH IS
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
POSITIONS.
THAT IS --
IN FISCAL YEAR.
NINETEEN AND IT IS OKAY. TO
SERVICE A COMPREHENSIVE SUITE OF
OF FIRE PREVENTION TOOLS AND AND
THE THE PERSONNEL TO MAKE SURE
THOSE TOOLS ALL ALL WORK
TOGETHER IN AN INTEGRATED
FASHION --
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ADDITIONAL
FIRE ENGINES INCREASED HEAVY
EQUIPMENT OPERATORS --
DEDICATED --
SEE SEE SEE FIRE CREWS AS AS
DIRECTOR SAIDO MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY --
THE C. ONE THIRTY AIR TANKERS
LARGE AIR TANKERS THAT WILL
EXTEND --
ALL OF OUR FLEET OF AIR TANKERS
INCLUDING THE S. TWOS WE
CURRENTLY RUN --
IT FOR UP TO THIRTY YEARS
FURTHER INTO THE FUTURE OF THEN --
PREVIOUSLY OF WERE CAPABLE OF
THE EMPLOYEE HEALTH AND WELLNESS.
AND OF OF CAL FIRE AND THEN --
FIRE DETECTION CAMERA AND MAKING
A ONE TIME MOBILE EQUIPMENT
REPLACEMENT FUNDING --
PERMANENT AGAIN THAT --
WHICH IS THE THREE THIRTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE'VE ASKED --
FOR TO PUT BACK IN OUR BUDGET.
THE AGAIN --
AL'S WITH --
ITEMS ARE NUMBER --
ONE ON THE CAL FIRE SIDE OF THAT
THE THE ASSEMBLY --
YOUR STAFF HAS DONE AN AMAZING
JOB.
ON OUTLINING WHAT EACH OF THESE --
ELEMENTS REALLY MEANS AND AND
WHAT THE FUNDING GOES --
TO SO OF THE SEVEN I DON'T WANT
TO GO INTO GREAT DETAIL IN THOSE --
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME BECAUSE
OF THE THE THE THE GREAT
ASSESSMENT THAT WAS DONE.
BUT I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT
THERE IS THESE ARE ALL --
CONSIDER TO BE --
IMPORTANT --
AS AS A WHOLE SUITE OF TOOLS --
I CAN'T SAY THAT ANY ONE OF THEM
IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN THE OTHER
ALL OF THEM WILL WORK TOGETHER --
TO WORK TOWARD MEETING OUR OUR
EXTENDED SEASON RESPONSE AS WELL
AS OUR FUEL REDUCTION --
PROJECT WORK --
AND PROVIDE THE CAL VIDEO OF US
TO MEET MEET OUR MISSION IN
DOING BOTH OF THOSE THINGS --
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
THIS IS AGAIN A A BALANCED
APPROACH --
AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY
AN INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS --
AT LOOKING AT NOT NECESSARILY
EVERYTHING THAT WE NEED --
GOING FORWARD INTO THE FUTURE
BUT RIGHT NOW THIS IS WHAT WE
KNOW WE NEED --
WHILE WE'RE MOVED IT MOVING
FORWARD AND DOING A FULL
ASSESSMENT OF THE DEPARTMENT'S
CAPABILITIES AND DEPLOYMENT
ACROSS THE STATE --
TO HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
OF OF WHAT WHERE WE ARE
POTENTIALLY DEFICIENT OR WHERE
WE NEED TO MOVE ON NEW OR
RESOURCES AROUND THE STATE IN
ORDER. TO TO BETTER SERVE THIS
ITEM -- WE
DO KNOW THAT.
THAT -- ARE
THE HEALTH AND WELLNESS OF OUR
OUR FIREFIGHTERS IS --
REALLY PARAMOUNT TO MAKING ALL
OF THIS WORK.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
FIREFIGHTERS AND THOSE THAT
SUPPORT THEM --
I GET THIS THE SUPPORT THEY NEED
FROM THE DEPARTMENT TO CONTINUE
DOING THIS THIS IMPORTANT WORK
[inaudible]
AND FINALLY.
RELATED --
TO COMMENT STAFF COMMENTS.
ON RC -- ONE
THIRTY APPROVED.
PROGRAM --
THEY'LL AO HAS THE THE THAT THIS
REMAIN OPEN WE UNDERSTAND THAT
WE ARE WORKING WITH LA --
TO PROVIDE THE INFORMATION THAT
HAS BEEN REQUESTED --
AND WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT YOU
THAT YOU HAVE THAT ANALYSIS ONCE
ONCE WE HAVE IT DONE.
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM A ALEJO.
THIS COMPUTERS WITH ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
AND I THINK JUST STARTING UP
VERY QUICKLY IN TERMS OF BIG
PICTURE SO YOU JUST DISCUSSED IN
THE AND FUNDING FOR IMPLEMENTING
THE LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE WHEN
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT OVERALL
WILD FIRE FUNDING THIS IS REALLY
THE OTHER BIG PIECE --
AND SO THAT THE GOVERNOR AND HIS
BUDGET WHERE HE'S GOING ABOVE
AND BEYOND WHAT'S REQUIRED --
BY CURRENT LAW THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE IS REALLY
FOCUSING ON ENHANCING FIRE
RESPONSE AND SUPPRESSION
CAPACITY.
IT'S A SORT OF IN CONTRAST TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE THAT WAS
MORE FOCUSED ON FOREST HEALTH
AND FIRE PREVENTION.
AND SO ONE THING THAT YOU'RE
GONNA WANT TO THINK ABOUT IS
YEAH AS YOU BALANCE THESE LARGER
FUNDING PRIORITIES AND YOU KNOW
IS ADDING EVERYTHING ABOVE AND
BEYOND WHAT'S REQUIRED IS DO YOU
WANT THAT ON THE FIRE RESPONSE
SIDE VERSUS.
DOING MORE FOREST HEALTH AND SO
SO THOSE GIVE ME SOME OF THE
ALSO FITS INTO YOUR OVERALL
BUDGET PACKAGE --
IN TERMS OF THE THE SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL HERE.
AND SO YOU TALKED A LITTLE BIT
AT YOUR HEARING LAST WEEK --
WITH RESPECT TO THAT PROPOSITION
PROPOSITION SIXTY AND SOME OF
THE TECHNICAL PROPOSALS HOW AND
OUR OFFICE AND I THINK
LEGISLATIVE STAFF THIS OR FELT
THERE IS A LACK OF OF DETAIL AND
THAT COULD.
SORT OF HINDER TRANSPARENCY IN
TERMS OF HAVING THE INFORMATION
NECESSARY FOR THE LEGISLATURE.
TO EVALUATE WHEN ADMINISTRATION
HAS TAKEN OR WHAT ON MAY BE IN
THE PAST WOULD HAVE BEEN
SEPARATE ISSUES ARE SEPARATE
PROPOSALS AND PACKAGE THEM.
TOGETHER THAT WAS SOMEWHAT THE
CASE WITH THIS --
PROPOSAL AS WELL AND SO IN TERMS
OF SORT OF TECHNICAL BUDGETING
SPEAK WE RECEIVED ONE AND BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL THAT HAD.
I'M ESSENTIALLY MULTIPLE
PROPOSALS --
WITHIN AS OUTLINED BY AT
DIRECTOR PORTER.
AND AND THAT ADDS UP TO THIS
ROUGHLY NINETY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FIND OUT AND
THAT'S REQUESTED.
AND AND THROUGH PACKAGING THOSE
THINGS TOGETHER WERE NOT --
PROVIDED AND THAT ADMINISTRATION
CAL FIRE AND FINANCE HAS BEEN
VERY RESPONSIVE AND PROVIDING US
WITH INFORMATION.
AND WE WOULD KNOW THAT THAT'S
MAYBE SOMEWHAT PROBLEMATIC JUST
IN THAT IT'S THAT'S NOT
AVAILABLE PUBLICLY AND SO FOR IN
OF THE LARGER PUBLIC AND FOR ON
GOING OVERSIGHT AND AND TRACKING
OF THE HISTORY AND THAT'S MAYBE
NOT AN IDEAL WAY TO DO THINGS.
AND THAT THE LACK OF INFORMATION
WAS PARTICULARLY PROBLEMATIC
WITH THIS SEE WHEN THIRTY
PROPOSAL.
AND THE AYE AYE AGAIN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BEEN VENN VERY
FORTHCOMING AND AND WORKING WITH
US THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS ON THAT.
ON THE FUNDING FOR THE SEA WHEN
THIRTIES GROWS CONSIDERABLY INTO
THE FUTURE YEARS AS MORE PLANES
ARE AT DELIVER THESE ESSENTIALLY
PLANES THAT THE STATE IS
RECEIVING FOR FREE FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
BUT WILL HAVE CONSIDERABLE COSTS
IN THE TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO OPERATE AND MAINTAIN
THOSE PLANES --
AND SO I APPRECIATE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TO HOLD ITEM
OPENED WE COMMIT TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH THE MINISTRATION.
TO GET THAT INFORMATION AND AND
REALLY AND WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT A LEGISLATURE ENSURE
THAT ALL OF THE PIECES OF
FUNDING.
I'M ARE JUSTIFIED AND MAKES
SENSE AND AND THAT IT FULLY
FINDS -- THE
THIS THE ONE THIRTY PROGRAM THAT
CALIFORNIA'S PROPOSING.
AND AND AND THAT THERE'S NOT
GOING TO BE A THAT YOU HAVE A
FULL PICTURE OF WHAT'S WHAT'S
REALLY GOING TO COST.
AND THE OTHER PIECE RELATED TO
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL IS AND IT --
DIRECTOR PORTERS ARE MENTIONED
THAT THESE ARE MAYBE NOT
EVERYTHING THAT THAT CAL FIRE
THINKS IT NEEDS TO DO BUT THESE
ARE THE INITIAL STEPS ARE THE
STEPS THIS YEAR THAT THEY COULD
TAKE.
AND IN THE CURRENT YEAR YOU
PROVIDED AND I THINK IT WAS A
CLOSE TO TURNER MILLION DOLLARS.
ENHANCING FIRE RESPONSE CAPACITY
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD BE ANOTHER
CLOSE TO ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS.
GIVEN THE CONDITION AND THE
SEVERITY OF FIRES IN THE STATE
IT'S VERY LIKELY THAT YOU'LL SEE
PROPOSALS OF THIS MAGNITUDE.
IN FUTURE YEARS --
AND WE WE JUST KNOW THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HASN'T PUT
FORWARD A RECENT ASSESSMENT THAT
WE FEEL ACCURATELY.
REALLY LAYS OUT WHAT IS THE FIRE
RISK RESPONSE CAPACITY IN THE
STATE -- AND
WHERE THE GAPS AND IS HAVING
THAT KIND OF BACKGROUND
INFORMATION TO REALLY HELP YOU
UNDERSTAND AS YOUR PERMIT YOU
KNOW APPROVING ARE BEING ASKED
TO APPROVE THIRTEEN A FIRE
ENGINES OR FUNDING FOR AIR
TANKERS AN INCREASING STAFFING
HOW DOES THAT FIT INTO THE
BIGGER PICTURE.
AND REALLY ENSURING THAT WHERE
YOU'RE PLACING YOUR LIMITED
DOLLARS IS MEETING THOSE HIGHEST
PARTY NEEDS.
I'M DIRECTOR PORTERS INDICATED
THAT CAL FIRE ON ON OF ITS OWN
INITIATIVE HAS ALREADY STARTED
WORKING ON AN ASSESSMENT SORT OF
ALONG THE LINES OF WHAT WE
RECOMMEND --
WE DO THINK THAT YOU MAY WANT TO
HAVE ON THE AND IF I CITY GOES
BEYOND JUST BUT TING THE
ACTIVATION STAND PARTNERS AND
FEDERAL PARTNERS.
AND REALLY UNDERSTANDING YOU
KNOW DOES IT MAKE MORE SENSE TO
HAVE MORE CAL FIRE ENGINES OR
SHOULD WE BE BOLSTERING THE
LOCAL AID SYSTEM AND WHAT'S THE
MORE COST EFFECTIVE APPROACH AND
DOES THAT DIFFER DEPENDING ON
WHAT REGION OF THE STATE.
AND AND AND AND THOSE TYPES OF
QUESTIONS AND SO WE WE WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT YOU AND EVEN EVEN
THOUGH HOW FAR THIRTY DURING
THIS ASSESSMENT WE RECOMMEND
THAT YOU REQUIRE AN ASSESSMENT.
AND THAT WOULD ALSO HELP THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE ASSESSMENT MEETS ITS GOALS
AND PROVIDES INFORMATION THAT WE
THAT WE REALLY THINK THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO NEED IN FUTURE YEARS.
AND YOU KNOW TO TO BE ABLE TO
KNOW THAT YOU KNOW THIRTEEN
THEIR ENGINES IS THE RIGHT
NUMBER FOR EXAMPLE AND AS AS
THESE REQUEST CONTINUE TO COME.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS.
MET MS GARCIA AND MISTER
PATTERSON.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO TO THAT REPORT IN
FACT THEY WERE TRYING TO LOOK
MORE HOLISTICALLY MOVING FORWARD
AS WE NOW HAVE A YEAR ROUND FIRE
SEASON --
JUST WANTED TO COMMENT ON THE
EMPLOYEE WELLNESS AND THE FACT
THAT WE'RE STARTING TO FOCUS ON
MENTAL HEALTH --
AND THE PTSD THAT THESE FIREMEN
ARE DEALING WITH AND I HOPE.
AS AS WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT
WE'RE TRACKING TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THROUGH THESE PILOTS THEY ARE
THE BEST WAY TO HELP OUR SERVICE
MEN OUT THERE THERE'S BEEN SOME
REPORTS OUT THERE OF THE
STRUGGLES AND WE WERE STILL THIS
YOU.
AND THE CRISIS THAT WE FORGET
THAT THESE THESE LONG JUST
WANTED TO COMMEND YOU ON THAT
BUT WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
TRACKING THAT ALONG THE WAY THAT
WE ARE.
YOU SEEN THE BEST SERVICES TO
HELP THESE INDIVIDUALS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENT AND WE
WILL.
MISTER PATTERSON.
JUST COUPLE OF REMIND ME HOW
MANY SEE ONE THIRTIES AND HOW
SOON DO YOU EXPECT THEM ONLINE.
I'M GONNA ASK --
CHIEF TYLER TO COVER THAT --
SPECIFICALLY.
HELLO SIR --
JOE TYLER I CAL FIRE CHIEF FIRE
PROTECTION.
YOUR QUESTION REGARDING C. ONE
THIRTIES --
THE NATIONAL DEFENSE
AUTHORIZATION ACT --
NGUYEN --
WORKING WITH THE UNITED STATES A
COAST GUARD IN THE UNITED STATES
AIRFORCE.
TO RETROFIT CURRENT S. C. ONE
THIRTY HERCULES MODEL AIRCRAFT
INTO --
CAPABLE AND EFFECTIVE A FIRE --
OVER A PERIOD OF TIME ENDING
HOPEFULLY BY AT TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR IN WHICH WE WILL
HAVE THE DELIVERY OF SEVEN A C.
ONE THIRTY AIRCRAFT.
OF THE SEVEN FIVE WILL GO IN
SERVICE --
TO WILL REMAIN AS MAINTENANCE
SPARES AND RESERVES [inaudible]
AND THE THE TIME FOR THE
HELICOPTERS COMING ON HOW SOON
IS THAT.
WE APPRECIATE THE THE FUNDING
THAT'S BEEN PROVIDED TO REPLACE
THE SUPER HUEY HELICOPTERS --
WE HAVE PURCHASED A TOTAL OF
FIVE OF THE A BLACK HAWK S.
SEVENTY AYE HELICOPTERS THE
FIRST HELICOPTER SHOULD ARRIVE --
BY MAY OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
AT MCCLELLAN WHICH IS OUR
AVIATION MANAGEMENT UNIT --
TO BE --
OPEN AND TRANSPARENT TO OF THE
SECOND S. SEVENTY AYE A
HELICOPTER THAT WAS BEING
TRANSPORTED ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES -- ON
A TRUCK TO TEXAS --
WAS INVOLVED IN A TRAFFIC
ACCIDENT --
IN TENNESSEE ON AN ICY ROAD --
THE SIKORSKY STAFF AS WELL AS
OUR STAFF --
HAVE EVALUATED IN SOUTH CAROLINA --
WORKING THROUGH A DISCUSSIONS ON
YOU WILL ACCEPTED AFTER REPAIRED --
AND THEN --
IF ACCEPTABLE WE SHOULD SEE THE
SECOND AIRCRAFT IN APPROXIMATELY
A HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS AFTER THE
MAY DELIVERY [inaudible] FIVE
WHAT IS THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
HELICOPTERS AUTHORIZED --
WE HAVE BEEN AUTHORIZED OVER OF
FOUR YEARS --
TWELVE HELICOPTERS TEN OF
WITCHER ARE IN SERVICE AND TO
ARM --
MAINTENANCE AND RESERVE.
AND OF THOSE TWELVE FIVE HAVE
BEEN PURCHASED AND ARE EITHER
HERE OR COMING.
SOON FIVE HAVE A PURCHASE ORDER
HAS BEEN WRITTEN FOR FIVE OF THE
AIRCRAFT OF THE NEXT --
FOUR THAT PURCHASE ORDER WOULD
BE --
WRITTEN IF APPROVED ON OR AFTER.
JULY FIRST OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JUST A QUICK COMMENT --
ON THE ISSUE OF OF FIRE FIGHTING
AIRCRAFT --
I HAD A CONVERSATION WITH US
SOMEONE RECENTLY WHO WAS QUITE
KNOWLEDGEABLE ON THE ON THE
OVERALL TOPIC --
AND IT WAS OBSERVED THAT THERE
NO --
FIREFIGHTING SPECIFIC AIRCRAFT
ANYWHERE AND EVERYTHING LIKE THE
AIRCRAFT YOU'RE JUST TALKING
ABOUT -- HAS
TO BE RETROFITTED --
AND TO THE DISCUSSION THAT
ENSUED WAS --
WHETHER IT WOULD BE MORE
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT TO FIND
A WAY -- TO
ORDER -- AND
CREATE A A AN AIRCRAFT THAT IS
SPECIFIC TO SOME OF THE VERY
SPECIFIC TASKS AT THE FIRE
SERVICE HAS --
SO I PUT THAT OUT THERE NOT FOR
TOPIC OF DISCUSSION TODAY BUT
SOMETHING TO THINK ABOUT I THINK --
CALIFORNIA IS NOT THE ONLY PLACE --
THAT IS SEEING INCREASED FIRE
RISK -- WE
KNOW THAT'S GOING TO CONTINUE ON
INTO THE FUTURE THERE ARE PLACES --
AS FAR FROM US IS --
PORTUGAL AND AUSTRALIA IN THE
UNITED STATES AND AROUND THE
WORLD THAT --
ACTUALLY COULD CREATE A MARKET
PLACE -- FOR
A FIRE SPECIFIC IT'S THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WOULD PROBABLY
REQUIRE THE COOPERATION OF THE
MILITARY IN SOME WAY.
BUT SOMETHING TO PONDER AND
THINK ABOUT AND WONDER WHETHER --
THAT MIGHT TO OVERTIME INCREASE
OUR OUR EFFECTIVENESS.
AND SO IT UP ON HIS RACE DID I
MISS YOU I APOLOGIZE I DID.
MISS PETERS --
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE?
THE ASSESSMENT THE LONG TERM
ASSESSMENT.
HOW DO YOU SEE THIS --
SPECIFIC REQUESTS COMING THROUGH --
WHO IS AT THE SHOULD PUT IT
TOGETHER WHO SHOULD OVERSEE IT?
HOW OFTEN SHOULD BE REVIEWED
WHAT ARE YOU ENVISIONING?
SURE SO AND WE WOULD ACTUALLY
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
REQUIRED THE ASSESSMENT RATHER
THAN JUST RELYING ON THE
MINISTRATION TO DO IT OF ITS OWN
VOLITION THAT WAY YOU HAVE --
THE ABILITY TO HAVE INPUT IN
TERMS OF WHAT GOES INTO IT AND
THE TIME LINES AS AND WHEN IT
COMES BACK TO YOU --
THAT YOU HAVE YOU KNOW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR HOW YOU CAN REQUIRE
REPORTS AND THE SUPPLEMENTAL
LANGUAGE REPORT THAT GOES ALONG
WITH THE BUDGET IS IS ONE OPTION.
AND AND WE THINK THAT THE HIGHER
BUT IN IN COORDINATION A WITH
THE OFFICE THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES --
AGAIN FOR THE REASON THAT WHILE
IT CALIFORNIA HAS AB YOU KNOW A
LOT OF THIS IS UNDER THEIR
PURVIEW.
AND WE WE DO THINK THAT THE
ASSESSMENT SHOULD REALLY LOOK AT
HOW CALIFORNIA RESOURCES AS WELL
AS MUTUAL AID SYSTEM SINCE WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT RESPONDING
TO AND SMALL FIRES AND CERTAINLY
VERY LARGE FIRES.
AND IT'S NOT JUST CAL FIRE
RESOURCES EVEN IF THE FIRE IS ON
THE STATE RESPONSIBILITY AREA
THAT THAT WE'RE OFTENTIMES
ACTIVATING THAT.
DOT MUTUAL AID SYSTEM AND SO.
ON JUST THINKING ABOUT AT WHAT
WHERE THE RESOURCES ARE GOING TO
BE THE MOST EFFECTIVE OR THE
MOST COST EFFECTIVE WILL HAVING
THAT HOLISTIC PICTURE SO WE
THINK THAT THE REQUIREMENTS
SHOULD BE ON CAL FIRE.
AND THAT THAT THEY ALSO
COORDINATE WITH --
YES AND WE LAY OUT IN OUR AND IN
OUR REPORT SPECIFIC THINGS THAT
WE THINK SHOULD BE LOOKED AT THE
CAPACITY.
GAPS IN CAPACITY LOOKING AT ALL
DIFFERENT TYPES OF OF
FIREFIGHTING RESOURCES SO FIRE
ENGINES AND AN AIRCRAFT AND THEY
CAME UP IN A JOINT HEARING LAST
WEEK LOOKING AT TECHNOLOGY AND
WHITE RENO ROLLED IS THERE FOR
EXAMPLE THE CAMERAS THAT ARE
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET.
AND AND AND ENSURE THIS IS SORT
OF A APPROACH AND TO ADDRESS
SAYING ADDRESSING WILDFIRES
LOOKING FORWARD AND AND WE'D BE
HAPPY TO IT SORT OF WORK WITH
YOU ON THE SPECIFICS OF WHAT
MIGHT GO INTO.
REQUIRE YOU KNOW THAT YOU WOULD
WANT TO HAVE REQUIRED AND NOT
ASSESSMENT AND WE DO THINK THE
PRIORITIZATION AND LINKING IT
BACK TO GOALS IS IMPORTANT THERE
HAVE BEEN SOME ASSESSMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN PUT OUT.
I'M SEVERAL YEARS BACK THAT AND
ARE MAYBE MORE OF JUST A SURVEY
OF YOU KNOW WHAT DO FOLKS WANT --
AS OPPOSED TO HAVING AS AS YOU
KNOW THAT FISCAL LOOK AT IT AS
WELL IF OKAY WELL WHAT DO WE
WHAT DO WE REALLY NEED AND IN
WHAT AREAS AND AND HOW DOES THAT
HELP US ACHIEVE SPECIFIC GOALS
HOW IS BACK IN AND IMPROVE THE
ABILITY IN A FIRE.
RESPONSE TIMES AND OR HOW WAS I
CAN APPROVE IMPROVE THE ABILITY
TO HANDLE MULTIPLE LARGE AND
WILD FIRE INCIDENTS THAT ARE
HAPPENING IN DIFFERENT AREAS OF
THE STATE AT THE SAME TIME.
IT CHIEF EARLIER WE TALKED ABOUT --
ONE OF MY QUESTIONS EARLIER
ABOUT HAVING THE THE LONG TERM
PLAN -- AND
GOES ALONG WITH THE ASSESSMENT
IS A SOMETHING THAT IS ALREADY
BEING IMPLEMENTED.
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT.
WHERE ARE WE ON THEM?
GREAT QUESTION MEMBER IS WHERE
WE ARE IS JUST STARTING WITH OUR
WITH OUR ASSESSMENT IT'S PART OF
OUR STRATEGIC PLAN THAT JUST
ROLLED OUT.
LAST MONTH.
OF FOR THE COMING OF FIVE YEARS.
AND SO WE ARE STARTING ON THAT --
WE HAVE NOT LAUNCHED YET --
BUT I DO WANT --
TO REFERENCE THAT IT IS A CAL
FIRE STRATEGIC PLAN ELEMENT.
AND CAL FIRES MISSION IS IS --
PRIMARILY FOR THE WILD LAND AND
THE S. R. RAY THIS IS SPECIFIC
TO THE WHAT OUR INTENT HAS BEEN
SPECIFICALLY TO LOOK AT WHAT WE
NEED. TO MANAGE OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES IN THE S. R.
RAY RELATED TO INITIAL ATTACK AN
EXTENDED ATTACK FROM THE CAL
FIRE PERSPECTIVE.
WE WILL --
BE COGNIZANT OF A OR SHOULD WE
GO FORTH AS WE PLAN --
WE WE WILL BE COGNIZANT OF THE
MUTUAL AID RESPONSE AND HOW THAT
FITS IN.
AND ALSO WORK WITH THOUGH YES TO
HELP US UNDERSTAND.
HOW THOSE RESOURCES ARE --
EITHER --
INCREASING OR DWINDLING
DEPENDING ON WHAT WHAT THEY HAVE
ASSESSED.
AND SO THAT WILL INFORM SOME OF
OUR DECISIONS BUT IT DOESN'T
CHANGE THAT CALIFORNIA'S PRIMARY
RESPONSIBILITY IS IS THAT
INITIAL ATTACK AN EXTENDED
ATTACK.
IN THE WILD LAND --
PRIVATE LANDS OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT AS
A STATE --
FIRST AND FOREMOST WITHOUT AND
THEN BRING IN THE SUPPORT FOR IT
TO BACK US UP AS THINGS CONTINUE
TO EXPAND THE AND GET BIGGER.
AND THAT DOES INCLUDE OUR
CONTRACT COUNTY PARTNERS AS WELL
SO ALL OF THIS WOULD INCLUDE --
ANY AREA WHERE THERE'S STATE
RESPONSIBILITY THAT'S BEING
COVERED.
AND EARLIER WE TALKED ABOUT
FORCED HEALTH I WOULD ASSUME
THAT TOO AS WE WERE WE'RE
LOOKING TO JUST AS YOU'VE TOP
YOU YOU'VE DESCRIBED HERE BUT
ALSO THE PREVENTION.
SO THAT WE HAVE LESS.
DAMAGE --
COMPARED TO WHAT WE CAN'T.
MORE RECENTLY.
IF YES AN END TO ADD ADD TO THIS --
WE WILL ALSO BE LOOKING AT THE
RESOURCES WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE MEETING THE INSPECTION
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT WE HAVE --
AS WELL AS THE THE ANNUAL --
IF THOSE A ANNUAL INSPECTIONS
BUT AS WELL AS THE ANNUAL WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE ON ON
FUELS PROJECTS AND COMMUNITY
DEFENSE PROJECTS --
AND AS WE IN ARE ARE YEAR ROUND
STAFFING PARTICULARLY WITH THE
FIRE ENGINES THAT THAT ARE
REFERENCED IN IN THIS BUDGET --
THOSE YEAR ROUND RESOURCES NOT
ONLY BY US THE THE THE FIRE THE
EXTRA FIRE RESOURCES DURING THE
PEAK OF FIRE SEASON AND EXTRA
FIRE ENGINES.
BUT THEY ALSO ALLOW US TO HAVE
STAFF AND THOSE ENGINES
AVAILABLE FOR DOING PRESCRIBED
BURNING.
FUELS PROJECTS AND INSPECTIONS
DURING THAT WINTER PERIOD WHERE
WHERE TYPICALLY OTHER RESOURCES
ARE ARE DOWN STAFF THOSE THAT
THOSE WILL REMAIN STAFFED AND BE
ABLE -- TO
INCREASE THOSE THOSE ASPECTS.
AND THEN FINALLY IF I MAY --
THE THERE'D BEEN SOME --
COMMENTS REGARDING THE
COLLECTION OF DATA AND HOW
IMPORTANT THAT IS FOR TO DIE YOU
WAIT THEY WERE REALLY ON TRACK
SHOULD WE BE MOVING OUR
RESOURCES TO A DIFFERENT AREA.
IN THE END WE WANT WHAT IS BEST
AND YOU'RE THE EXPERTS TO BE
ABLE TO EVALUATE THIS TO TELL US
YOU YOU HAVE THIS AMOUNT OF
MONEY AND HOW DO WE HOW DO WE
PLACE THE MONEY.
IN THE RIGHT PLACE AND WE HAVE
TO MOVE IT.
HOW DO WE MOVE IT SO IN THE
COLLECTION OF DATA ARE ARE ARE
YOU ARE YOU PARTICIPATING IN
DETERMINING WHAT THE DATA IS IT
NEEDS TO BE COLLECTED --
HOW WHAT IS THE PROCESS FOR THAT
WHERE IS THAT DATA COLLECTED
WARS IT WHERE IS IT?
WHOSE EVALUATING.
THE AND THAT'S THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION AS WELL AND AND WE WILL
EVALUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF OF
THESE FIRE SUPPRESSION AND FUELS
RELATED RESOURCE --
AGAINST OUR TARGETS --
FOR DOING THOSE TYPES OF WORK --
WHEN IT COMES TO THE GRANT
PROGRAMS THAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT PREVIOUSLY THE THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION AND THE AND THE
THE THE MONEY THAT'S GOING TO BE
GOING OUT TO PROJECT WORK ON THE
GROUND?
WE WILL ASSESS THE THE AFFECTS
OF THOSE AND ALSO --
INTEGRATE THE MAP WE HAVE A
MAPPING TOOL THAT WILL SHOW THE
INTEGRATION OF THOSE PROJECTS AS
THEY'RE BEING COMPLETED.
AND AND SHOW HOW --
THE FEDERAL PROJECTS THAT ON
FEDERAL LAND AND THEN THE
PRIVATE LAND PROJECTS AND THEN
THE PRIVATE TIMBER TIMBER
INDUSTRY PROJECTS AND ALL THESE
DIFFERENT PROJECTS THAT ARE
GOING ON ON THE LANDSCAPE WILL
ALL BE.
VIEWABLE ON A MAP SO YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO START TO SEE IN
WATERSHEDS THE CRITICAL MASS OF
WORK THAT'S BEING DONE --
THAT WILL ALL BE A PART OF THE
THE THE SOLUTION ON THAT PIECE --
COMING BACK TO THE PREVIOUS ITEM
A COUPLE OF THE MONITORING OF
PIECES WERE RELATED --
TO HOW WE'RE WORKING WITH OUR
OUR COUNTERPARTS --
UNDER AGENCY.
OUR WATER AND AND FISH AND
WILDLIFE --
A LOT OF WHAT THE THE MONITORING
THAT WILL COME IN THE REPORTING
THAT WILL COME OUT OF THOSE --
WILL BE --
ALSO INFORMED BY BY OUR ACTIVITY
AND OUR MONITORING OF OF THE
EXEMPTIONS --
FOR THESE THESE TYPE OF FUEL
REDUCTION --
EXEMPTIONS THAT ARE AT THAT ARE
COMING OUT OF SB --
NINE OH ONE AND THAT WILL BE
REPORTED THROUGH OUR REGULAR
PROCESS THROUGH THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY AND AVAILABLE --
AS WELL TO THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE AND THE PUBLIC THROUGH
THROUGH THAT --
AND THEN A ONE LAST ONE I WANTED
TO TOUCH ON BECAUSE I REALLY
LIKE -- TO
HEARING WHERE --
A. R. B. IS AND AND OUR OUR
COOPERATIVE WORK --
THERE TO WORK TO INCREASE OF
THROUGH --
DATA DRIVEN --
YOU KNOW.
MEANS -- IN
ORDER TO DO THAT THIS P. FIRST
PROGRAM THAT WE HEARD ABOUT --
REALLY IS IT'S VOLUNTARY BUT IT
IS CRITICAL THAT WE PUT ALL OF
THOSE ALL OF THAT DATA INTO THAT
PROGRAM TO BE ABLE.
TO GET A A BROAD LOOK AT WHAT.
WHAT WE REALLY WHAT IMPACT WE
REALLY ARE HAVING AND HOW THOSE
IMPACTS THEN ARE ABLE --
TO REDUCE THE IMPACTS OF OF A
PARTICULAR MATTER IN PARTICULAR.
I WAS A LITTLE TONGUE TWISTER --
RELATED TO WILDFIRES SO.
ALL THAT IS PART OF WHAT WE'RE
DOING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
YOU'RE WELCOME --
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SO WE ARE GOING --
TO ASK THOSE WHO MIGHT HAVE HAD
A PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE TO TO
DO THAT JUST BEFORE WE VOTE ON
ISSUE --
THREE BECAUSE ISSUE TOO IS A
HOLD OPEN SO LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE THREE WHICH IS SET AT AND
THEN FROM.
PICTURE I GET TO THE RIGHT PAGE.
THE ONES YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
THAT MAKES THE OKAY ONE SECOND I
AM SORRY.
RIGHT THIS IS A BEEN A HEFTY.
HERE I HAVE A MALL IN ORDER.
DATA AND INFORMATION SYSTEMS
AREA.
OKAY [inaudible]
MY APOLOGIES.
ALL RIGHTS --
HELP FIRES REQUESTING THREE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND AND SEVEN SEVEN
POINT EIGHT POSITIONS. TO MEET
THE REQUIREMENTS OF AB A A LEVIN --
TWENTY NINE THE LAST SESSION --
YOU KNOW FROM LAST SESSION SO --
THIS IS OUR EMERGENCY MEDICAL
CARE -- DATA
REQUIREMENT THAT WE WE WE NEED --
TO PROVIDE IN A DAY IN
ELECTRONIC FORM THROUGH A
PROGRAM THAT THAT IS FEDERALLY
MANDATED --
AND AND THAT DATA IS THEN
AVAILABLE TO THE THIRTY THREE
EMERGENCY SERVICES --
AGENCIES AS WELL AS THE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY --
THIS WILL ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT
TO MEET THE THE MANDATED --
CRITERIA OF OF PROVIDING --
ELECTRONIC PATIENT CARE DATA --
THAT WILL THEN BE LOOKED AT
STATISTICALLY --
BY THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES AUTHORITY AND THEN --
AND ALSO --
WE CAN YOU DEVELOP OUR SURE IT'S
PROGRAM. TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE --
MEETING THE HIGH QUALITY CARE
THAT THE PUBLIC EXPECTS FROM OUR
EMS [inaudible]
THANK YOU AND THE LA OVER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE DON'T
HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS.
WE NEED TO TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
FIRST BUT TO IS THERE PUBLIC
COMMENT YES.
THERE'S A LOT OF WHITE SHIRTS
BACK THERE SO.
JOSH DUGGAR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION CAN'T OF
COUNTIES JUST QUICKLY ON THE
ISSUE -- TO
JUST WANTED TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE FUNDING REQUESTED IN THAT
BC P. WHILE THEY'RE STATE
RESOURCES THEY HAVE A CLEAR AND
APPRECIATED --
BENEFIT TO THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES
AND THE INDIVIDUAL THE HEALTH OF
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT PROVIDE
THOSE SERVICES SO THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
QUESTION NUMBER.
THREE CARRILLO [inaudible]
I FONG.
GARCIA.
MULLIN PATTERSON.
YES [inaudible]
REQUEST.
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
MOVE NOW DO ISSUE FOR ENHANCED
INDUSTRIAL DISABILITY LEAVE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO. FOR THIS ONE CAL FIRE IS
REQUESTING FOUR POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS A GENERAL FUND --
IN THIS --
COMING FISCAL YEAR ONLY THAT'S
NINETEEN TWENTY FOR THE
ESTIMATED INCREASE IN WORK AND
WORKERS COMPENSATION.
AND OVERTIME COSTS FOR BACK FILL
BEHIND INJURED --
WORKERS --
THE NEW LAWS.
THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH --
SB. THREE THIRTY FOUR PREVIOUS
AND THEN --
LAST YEAR SB --
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR HAVE INCREASED --
THE COSTS AND WELL CAL FIRE IS
ASKING FOR THIS AS WE DID LAST
YEAR IT'S THE SAME AMOUNT --
LAST YEAR WAS A FOUR POINT --
TWO JUST FOR THE THE SB. THREE
THIRTY FOUR WE'RE ASKING FOR THE
SAME AMOUNT BECAUSE WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE IMPACTS WILL BE --
WE HAVE --
ASKED FOR A MECHANISM TO BE
INCLUDED FOR FUNDING THAT MAY --
GO BEYOND THAT NUMBER --
AND THIS IS ALL A IN THE INTERIM
UNTIL WE HAVE DETERMINED OF A
BASELINE COST ADJUSTMENT THAT WE
WILL NEED TO ASK FOR PERMANENTLY
IN THE FUTURE.
Q. L. L. FINANCE.
NO CONCERNS WITH THIS.
IS THERE PUBLIC COMMENT.
WE HAVE A RECOMMENDATION TO
APPROVE ON ISSUE.
FOR THANK YOU THEIR SECOND.
BLOOM I FONG AYE GARCIA.
MULLIN PATTERSON.
RAY YES LUZ RIVAS.
ISSUE FIVE FACILITIES REPAIRS
AND MAINTENANCE.
THANK YOU KNOW IF WE NEED.
TO HAVE A REPORT FROM THE CHIEF
FIRST [inaudible]
PLEASE.
THANK YOU CHAIR BLOOM --
I HAVE --
ASKED -- TO
MIKE DUGGAN TO JOIN ME --
JUST IN THE EVENT THAT THERE
QUESTIONS THAT THE THAT HIM HE'S
OUR TECH SERVICES CHIEF.
SO CAL FIRE IS REQUESTING NINE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND AND TWENTY TWO
POINT THREE POSITIONS --
IN --
NINETEEN TWENTY CLOUT WITH THE
ADDITIONAL WITH THIS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING --
IT.
IT ITH ADDITIONAL FUNDING AT TO
COME IN STE IN IN SUBSEQUENT
YEARS I'M SORRY --
THIS IS TO BUILD CAPACITY.
UNDER OUR OUR CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM AND MAIN
MAINTAIN --
THAT MAINTAIN THE PROPERTIES
THAT WE HAVE THAT ARE ARE AGING --
WE HAVE --
OVER TWO THOUSAND STRUCTURES IN
FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FACILITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
AND WE ARE SEEING A BACKLOG AND
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE --
AND THAT IS TRUE THAT REQUIRE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING AND STAFFING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE DOING
THE ROOT ROUTINE MAINTENANCE --
AND SCHEDULED.
MAINTENANCE NEEDED --
TO KEEP --
OPERABLE.
SO -- BOTH
THE STAFFING AND THE FUNDING ARE
IMPORTANT --
TO ENVOY AVOID THE ACCUMULATION
OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AS AS
PREVIOUSLY STATED.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
IN THIS.
THESE.
THANK YOU AN AREA OTHER COMMENTS.
DOES COMPUTERS AT THE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND SO WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THIS SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL BUT WE WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT IN TERMS OF HOW YOU THINK
ABOUT DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ONE
OF THE ON THINGS THAT OUR OFFICE
HAS.
BEEN RECOMMENDING FOR SOME TIME
IS THAT DEPARTMENTS AND
ESTABLISH A IN ONGOING
MAINTENANCE BUDGET THAT ALLOWS
THEM TO AVOID BEING IN THE
SITUATION OF HAVING A LOT OF
ACCUMULATED DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
WHICH CAN BE.
MORE COSTLY TO DEAL WITH IN THE
LONG RUN --
THERE'S BEEN SEVERAL DEPARTMENTS
UNDER THE PURVIEW OF THIS
COMMITTEE THAT HAVE DONE THIS
AND THIS IS.
CAL FIRES A PROPOSAL FOR THIS
YEAR WE WE THINK THAT THAT TIME
IS REASONABLE AND IS ARE
GENERALLY GOOD PRACTICE TO
MAINTAIN THINGS ON THE FRONT AND
AND AND SUPPOSED TO WAITING FOR
THEM. TO TO DEGRADE --
AND THIS IS ALSO JUST GOING TO
RELATE TO THE ITEM THAT YOU
HEARD AND AND I BELIEVE APPROVED
LAST WEEK ON THE LARGER DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROPOSAL FOR THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY.
I AM IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE
THAT YOU'RE HAVING ON GETTING
ENOUGH INFORMATION BACK ON HOW
THOSE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FUNDS
ARE BEING SPENT.
AND WHAT'S HAPPENING TO THE
BACKLOG OF DEFERRED THAT CAO
FIRES DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
BACKLOG AND HAS STOPPED GROWING
AND AND POTENTIALLY HAS EVEN
DECLINED OVER TIME AS YOU'RE
PROVIDING THIS ONE TIME DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FUNDS.
AS WELL AS ADDRESSING --
THE FUNDING FOR THEM TO TO HAVE
ONGOING MAINTENANCE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
FINANCE OF HER --
EIGHT IS THERE PUBLIC COMMENT OR
QUESTIONS.
AND NOW WE HAVE A RECOMMENDATION --
TO APPROVE THE BCP IN THE
TRAILER BILL.
BLOOM AYE FONG AYE GARCIA.
MULLIN PATTERSON.
REYES REVERSE.
THANK YOU I WILL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE SIX FIREWORKS MANAGEMENT
AND DISPOSAL AND A
RECOMMENDATION.
TO UP -- WE
JUST FIND HERE TO OF APPROVAL ON
AN ITEM THAT HAS LONG BE DOUBLED
US SO.
IT'LL BE NICE TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD.
CHIEF THANK YOU --
CAL FIRE IS REQUESTING THREE A
THREE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND TO INCREASED.
THE STATE'S OVERALL FIRE
PREVENTION EFFORTS AND REDUCE
THE INFLUX OF OF ILLEGAL
FIREWORKS INTO THE STATE --
DOWN TO INCREASE EDUCATION AND
ENFORCEMENT --
OF OF FIREWORKS --
REGULATIONS AND LAW.
THE THE THE FUNDS WILL ALSO.
COVER THE COST OF DISPOSAL OF
THESE WHEN WHEN THEY ARE SEIZED.
AND AND THEN THAT IS AN
EXPENSIVE VENTURE AND AND IT
REQUIRES SHIPPING THESE
MATERIALS OUT OF STATE.
I HAVE I BROUGHT UP A DANIEL
BURR LANTER --
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR FIRE
MARSHAL I IN CASE THERE ARE ANY
SPECIAL QUESTIONS --
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR PLANT --
I BET THIS IS GONNA COMES A
RELEASED HERE.
THIS ISSUE IS BEING OF MYSELF
AND OF COURSE --
ACCU STATE FIRE MARSHAL MIKE OF
RICH WHITE WHOSE WERE --
WE TO LOOK FOR TO BRING IN A
LONG TERM SOLUTION --
TO YOU THEN HOPEFULLY WE CAN
PASS AND AND MOVE FORWARD.
THAT SOUNDS COULD OF ANY --
I WOULD EVER OF FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO MIGHT NOT BE FAMILIAR WITH
THIS ISSUE WE HAVE --
ACCUMULATED AT AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF I GUESS WE COULD CALL
IT ORDINANCE BUT IT'S EXPLOSIVE
MATERIAL --
THAT WERE UNABLE TO SHIP
ANYWHERE ELSE --
OUR WAREHOUSES ARE FULL --
IT'S A FRANKLY AT A FAIRLY
DANGEROUS SITUATION WOULD YOU
AGREE THAT THE MARCH YEAH
ABSOLUTE THESE ARE EXPLOSIVE
ITEMS -- WE
DO HAVE THEM IN STORAGE WE ARE
RE LEE --
YOU US --
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS --
IN A SHORT TERM SOLUTIONS WE ARE
HOPING THAT THIS WILL PROVIDE US
A LONG TERM STABLE A FUNDING
SOURCE SO THAT WE CAN ONCE AND
FOR ALL I NOT ONLY HAVE A
DISPOSAL --
PROGRAM BUT ALSO INCREASE OUR
ENFORCEMENT AND EDUCATION WHICH
IS LACKING AND WHICH WE HOPE
WILL THEN TURNED TO REDUCING THE
AMOUNT THAT NEEDS TO BE DISPOSED
OF THAT SOUNDS GOOD I THINK YOU
KNOW THE CONTROVERSY HAS LONG
BEEN -- WHAT
THE FUNDING SOURCE WOULD BE --
GENERAL FUND IS NOT MY FIRST
CHOICE BUT THIS IS SOMETHING WE
JUST NEED TO MOVE FORWARD SO --
WILL TAKE A IN MY VIEW SECOND
BEST IS --
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THIS IS SUCH A
DANGEROUS.
SITUATION --
MISERY THIS.
THANK YOU I HAVE A QUICK
QUESTION I'M MORE TO THE
FIREWORKS --
GET CHIP TO OUT OF STATE.
WE ARE ACTUALLY IN THE PROCESS
RIGHT NOW SUPPOSE OF THEM A
COUPLE AYE EPA --
APPROVED FACILITIES --
NONE OF WHICH ARE IN CALIFORNIA --
I BELIEVE THERE ARE TWO
FACILITIES --
IN THE EASTERN PORTION.
OF THE THE THE U. S. --
THAT CAN DISPOSE OF THESE IN A
SAFE MANNER --
SO THERE IS A COST TO TO TO DO
THAT TO SHIP THEM WE ESTIMATE --
THAT IT'S ABOUT TEN DOLLARS A
POUND -- IN
ORDER TO NOT ONLY SHIP THEM BUT
TO IN A SAFE MANNER DISPOSABLE.
OKAY THANK YOU MS GARCIA.
UP THANK YOU CHAIR AND SO WHILE
THE GENERAL FUND THIS IN ANY OF
OUR PREFERRED SPOT I'M
APPRECIATIVE OF THIS THAN.
THE ENFORCEMENT TO COME DOWN THE
ROAD MY DISTRICT BECOMES A WAR
ZONE -- AND
MY A LOCAL MY LOCALLY SENATE
THAT HEALTH AND AND THE DISPOSAL
SO APPRECIATE THAT WITH VALLEY
HANDLING THIS AND HOPEFULLY.
REDUCTION IN AN ACTIVITY IN THE
FUTURE AS WELL.
IT MIGHT SURPRISE YOU MISS
GARCIA THAT MY DISTRICT --
FOR ON THE FOURTH OF JULY --
HERE'S A LOT OF POP INTO YEAH.
MOST OF OUR STATE PRETTY WIDE.
YES MR Và I HAVE A QUICK
QUESTION JUST A CURIOSITY SO WE
SHIP THESE FIREWORKS.
UP OUT OF THE STATE WHY CAN'T WE
DISPOSE IN CALIFORNIA.
I IN IN THE IN THE PAST --
WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
TREATMENT METHODS THAT JUST IN
TODAY'S WORLD ARE NO LONGER
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY --
SO THE EPA DOES --
CERTIFY TWO LOCATIONS --
IN OTHER STATES THAT ARE ABLE TO
TREAT THESE FIREWORKS IN THE
MOST COST EFFECTIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND SAFEST MANNER.
SO WE HAVE A ARE --
TO HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND LA --
AND FINANCE HAVE NO COMMENTS SO --
WAS GONNA MOTION IS OUR SECOND.
HELLO I FONG.
GARCIA.
MULLIN PATTERSON.
RAY YES RIVER.
OUR NEXT ITEM AS SEVEN
PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS PROGRAM
CONTINUATION.
THE RECOMMENDATION TO HOLD OPEN
SO WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
BEFORE ISSUE --
EIGHT CHIEF.
AGAIN I SHOULD'VE BEEN SORTING.
OUR PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS
PROGRAM.
THIS.
AND FOR THAT.
ONE YOU'RE STANDING COMMITTEES
TAKE YOURS.
SO -- OUR
PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS PROGRAM --
IT IS AS AS YOU KNOW AND HAVE
HAVE BEEN A PART OF IN IN --
PREVIOUS YEARS --
SETTING UP OR HELPING US SET UP
IT IS --
CURRENTLY FUNDED --
ON A TEMPORARY BASIS AND SO WE
ARE ASKING --
FOR FOUR MILLION DOLLARS --
WHICH IS TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
OF GENERAL FUND --
AND THEN ALSO --
ONE ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS WORTH OF
GREENHOUSE GAS BONDS.
AND ONE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS OF REIMBURSED REACHED
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY --
FOR FOURTEEN POSITIONS --
TO CONTINUE THE FOREST'S AT THE
PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS PROGRAM
[inaudible]
ANY QUESTIONS.
IS AND THE AGAIN I SAID --
THIS ONE IS HOLD OPEN SO WILL --
ON COLD TO PUBLIC COMMENT BEFORE
ISSUE [inaudible]
EIGHT AND SO.
WITH NO QUESTIONS WILL MOVE ON
NOW TO ISSUE EIGHT THAT'S THE
VARIOUS CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS.
OKAY.
THANK YOU AND SO VARIOUS CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS --
THIS THIS REQUEST IS IS A FORTY
BILLION DOLLAR --
REQUEST --
FOR FIFTEEN CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS INCLUDING ACQUISITION
PRELIMINARY PLANS --
WORKING DRAWINGS --
CONSTRUCTION AS WELL AS MINOR
PROJECTS.
THESE PROJECTS HAVE BEEN --
IN THE CALIFORNIA --
FIVE YEAR INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN.
FOR MULTIPLE YEARS AND RECENTLY
OUR MAYBE INNER EMILY HAVE
DROPPED OFF AT DIFFERENT POINTS --
IS DUE TO A GENERAL FUND OF
FUNDING CONSTRAINTS DURING THE
RECESSION --
WHAT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE IS
THESE THESE ARE --
PROJECTS THAT SHOW AS NEW --
BUT THEY ARE OLD PROJECTS TO THE
PLAN THEY HAVE BEEN ON THE PLAN
FOR IT IN THE PAST.
APPROXIMATELY 80% OF
CALIFORNIA'S --
FACILITIES WERE CONSTRUCTED PRE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SO WE HAVE A A
LIFE CYCLE OF OF APPROXIMATELY
FIFTY YEARS ON ON OUR STRUCTURES
AND AND WE HAVE REACHED THAT IN
MANY OF IN MANY CASES --
THE OLDER FACILITIES --
ARGUE ARE NO LONGER LARGE ENOUGH
TO FIT THE CURRENT FIRE ENGINES --
AN APPARATUS THAT WE HAVE --
THEY HAVE --
THEY ARE NOT BUILT TO CURRENT
CODES -- AND
THEY ALSO HAVE.
SOME CHALLENGES WITH THE BERRICS
IS THAT ARE NOT --
IT IS SUITABLE TO TODAY'S
WORKFORCE --
MEANING THEY'RE VERY OPEN AND
NOT A LOT OF PRIVACY --
FOR DIFFERENT PEOPLE AND GENDER
RELATED ISSUES --
ARE ARE A RESTROOM FACILITIES
ARE VERY MUCH IN THAT SAME KIND
OF OPEN FORMAT AND REALLY WERE --
CREATED FOR A SINGLE GENDER TYPE
ISSUES.
THAT IS WHERE WE ARE WITH THIS
REQUEST.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU --
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON
HELLO.
SEARCH ASSEMBLY AWESOME COMMENTS
OUT YET JUST A NO WE DON'T WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THAT THE PROPOSAL'S BUT JUST TO
TEN NOTE FOR YOUR LONGER TERM
BUDGET PLANNING THAT.
I'M AT THE FORTY MILLION THAT'S
PROPOSED FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS FOR CALIFORNICUM ONLY
IN IN THE BUDGET YEAR IS TO
INITIATE NINE NEW PROJECTS THAT
WOULD BE FUNDED FROM THE GENERAL
FUND.
THOSE NINE PROJECTS ARE GOING TO
HAVE TOTAL I IN ORDER TO DESIGN
AND CONSTRUCT THOSE PROJECTS.
WHO -- I AM
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP SO --
LET'S MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT
FOR ISSUES --
SEVEN AND EIGHT SEEING NO ONE
STEP FORWARD WE HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION ON ISSUE EIGHT TO
APPROVE.
SOME OF THE YOU.
BLOOM I FONG.
GARCIA.
MULLIN PATTERSON.
RADIUS REVERSE.
WHICH TAKES US TO OUR LAST ISSUE
OF THE DAY ISSUE.
NINE CONTRACT COUNTY CAPITAL
OUTLAY.
WELL THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE RIGHT BETWEEN
YOU AND YOUR LUNCH.
BUT I AM THE LESS.
SO.
THIS IS OUR CONTRACT COUNTY --
CAPITAL OUTLAY --
REQUEST CAL FIRE IS REQUESTING --
THREE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS AND TO RESTORE
STATUTORILY REQUIRED --
PROPORTIONAL FUNDING TO THE SIX
CONTRACT COUNTIES OF LOS ANGELES
ORANGE COUNTY SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY --
VENTURA COUNTY AND KERN COUNTY
AND MARIN COUNTY CZ ALMOST WENT
BACK TO MONTEREY.
IT SHOULDN'T DO THAT IN MARIN
COUNTY --
THIS REQUEST IS --
IS RELATED TO AN AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THAT COULD THE SIX
CONTRACT COUNTIES --
TO HAVE A PROPORTIONAL --
ALLOCATION THAT IS APPROXIMATELY
19% OF WHAT OF WHAT --
THEY CAL FIRE ALLOCATION.
IS AND IT'S A LIKE FOR LIKE --
FROM THE PRIOR --
CAPITAL OUTLAY --
BUDGET YEAR.
SO -- THE
THREE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS --
IT WOULD BE ADJUSTED --
BASED ON THAT 19% OF WHAT CAL
FIRES --
ALLOCATION IS --
AND THAT IS WHAT OUR
RECOMMENDATION AND AND WHAT --
IT MEETS THE METHOD ALL SET UP
IN AGREEMENT WITH THE SIX
CONTRACT COUNTIES.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS [inaudible]
OHIO [inaudible]
AND SO.
WE THINK THAT IT'S REASONABLE TO
CONSIDER GIVING I'M CAPITAL A
FUNDING TO THE CONTRACT COUNTY
SUBCONTRACT COUNTIES ARE
PROVIDING A SERVICE TO CAL FIRE
AND HAVING FIRE STATIONS AND
OTHER FACILITIES IS NECESSARY IN
ORDER FOR THEM TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES.
ON THE FUNDING OF FOR THIS
PURPOSE HAVE I WAS ELIMINATED IN
THAT TWELVE THIRTEEN BUDGET AND
SO HASN'T BEEN PROVIDED FOR THE
BETTER PART OF THE LAST DECADE --
IF IT'S A PRIORITY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AS YOU'RE PUTTING
TOGETHER YOUR OVERALL GENERAL
FUND PRIORITIES TO REINSTATE THE
SPENDING WE DO THINK IT'S YOU
KNOW IT'S A REASONABLE AND
APPROPRIATE.
AND THOUGH THE FORMULA AND THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
TO REINSTATE THOUGH WE FIND IT
DOESN'T REALLY TRACK WITH WHAT
THE NEEDS ARE.
AND THERE'S ACTUALLY A LOT OF
VARIABILITY IN THE FUNDING FOR
THAT SO HOW THAT FORMULA THAN A
PLACE OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS.
THE ANNUAL AMOUNT OF FUNDING
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN PROVIDED
FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY FOR CONTRACT
COUNTIES WOULD HAVE RANGED FROM
NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
ONE YEAR TO BE SPLIT AMONGST THE
SIX COUNTIES.
SO NOT VERY MUCH --
IT TO A HIGH OF NINE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE HIGHEST
YEAR AND THIS IS BECAUSE THE WAY
THE FORMULA WORKS AS A
PERCENTAGE BUT IT'S A PERCENTAGE
BASED ON THE CAPITAL OUTLAY
EXPENDITURES. FOR CALIFORNICA LE
HERE AND SO CONSTRUCTION AND THE
SAME YEAR THAT'S GOING TO BE A
VERY SORT OF HI TAKE THAT AMOUNT
TAKE 19% OF THAT.
VERSES AND A YEAR WHERE MAYBE
CAL FIRE JUST HAPPENS TO HAVE
NOT NOT ANY PROJECT STARTING
CONSTRUCTION HAPPENED ALL BE IN
A DESIGN PHASE FOR THE COSTS ARE
LOWER.
I AND SO THIS CAN CREATE A LOT
OF VARIABILITY IN THE FUNDING
AND THAT COULD COMPLICATE AND
THE ABILITY FOR CONTRACT
COUNTIES TO PLAN FOR USING THAT
FUNDING.
AND AND IT'S JUST NOT REALLY
TIED TO ANY ACTUAL CAPITAL
OUTLAY NEEDS.
AND THE SO WE WOULD KNOW THAT
IT'S PROBABLY NOT COST EFFECTIVE
TO GET THE INFORMATION TO
ACTUALLY TRACK WHAT THE SPECIFIC
NEEDS ARE KIDS IT'S QUITE
COMPLICATED YOU HAVE LOCAL FIRE
STATIONS THAT ARE SERVING
MULTIPLE PURPOSES.
BOTH AND DOING THE CONTRACT
COUNTY WORK ON STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREAS AS WELL AS
LOCAL RESPONSIBILITIES AND AND
SO.
AND IT MIGHT NOT REALLY BE
PRUDENT TO TRY TO GET THE
INFORMATION TO HAVE SOME SORT OF
NEEDS BE BASED APPROACH.
AND SO WE THINK THAT MAYBE JUST
A SIMPLER APPROACH OF PICKING
AMOUNT AND SET THAT AMOUNT IF
YOU WANT TO PROVIDE THIS FUNDING
AND THAT WAY YOU CAN PROVIDE A
STABLE LEVEL OF FUNDING AND FROM
EACH YEAR.
AND TO ADD A POINT THAT I KNOW --
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES
INDICATE IN THE PAST AS WELL IF
THE STATE IS IN A POSITION TO
SHUT OFF OUR CAPITAL OUTLAY
FUNDING BECAUSE OF BUDGET
CONSTRAINTS YOU COULD ALWAYS DO
THE SAME THING EVEN IF YOU.
SET A SPECIFIC AMOUNT.
AND HOW YOU CHOOSE THAT AMOUNT
YOU COULD PICK THE AMOUNT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUT IN THE BUDGET FOR
THIS YEAR WHICH IS THE THREE
POINT THREE MILLION WE LOOKED AT
WHAT THAT FUNDING WOULD HAVE
BEEN OVER THE LAST ROUGHLY TEN
YEARS THE AVERAGE OF THAT SPOT
TWO POINT TWO MILLION --
OR YOU CAN PICK SOME OTHER
AMOUNT THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH AND YOU COULD
ALWAYS SET UP A PROCESS.
TO HAVE IT --
INCREASE AND WITH CHANGE AND SO
THE REASONABLE IF IT'S ONE OF
YOUR PRIORITIES BUT WE THINK
THERE'S PROBABLY A SIMPLER WAY
TO PROVIDE FUNDING.
ALL RIGHT --
WITH THAT ARE THERE A DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SURE JUST A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS SO I AM JUST WANT TO
NOTE THAT THIS METHODOLOGY IS
THE METHODOLOGY THAT WE'VE USED
HISTORICALLY IT'S NOT ARBITRARY
THAT NINETEEN POINT 29%.
AND CAL FIRE CAN SPEAK BETTER TO
THAT THAN I BUT IT'S IT'S BASED
ON SORT OF A LIKE FOR LIKE IN
TERMS OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THAT --
THE CONTRACT COUNTIES HAVE IN
PROPORTION TO THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS AND IN AND
WE'RE NOT AWARE OF ANY CONCERNS
WITH THE METHODOLOGY.
AND YEAH BUT YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
THE LA --
CONCERNS WERE NOT AWARE OF ANY
CONCERNS FROM THE CONTRACT
COUNTIES AND AND THIS IS REALLY
THAT --
METHODOLOGY OR SORT OF THE VERY
ABILITY AND FUNDING IS
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT WE DO FOR
OUR STATE CAPITAL OUTLAY PROGRAM
MEANING WE HAVE SORT OF VARYING
AMOUNTS OF FUNDING FROM YEAR TO
YEAR THAT WE AT BRING BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THIS IS A RECOMMENDATION.
TO YEAH WE HAVE A RECOMMENDATION
TO HOLD OPEN AND WE'LL TAKE
PUBLIC PUBLIC COMMENT THAT.
THIS OUR LAST ITEM SO.
THANK YOU --
BLOOM MEMBERS THE ASSEMBLY CASE
AND WEBER ASSOCIATION OF
CONTRACT TOWNIES.
AND DAYLIGHT IS THE MARIN COUNTY
FIRE CHIEF --
YOU KNOW FIRST THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND RE
ESTABLISHING THIS FUNNY AND IT'S
AN IMPORTANT PART OF WHAT WE DO
IN PARTNERSHIP --
YOU KNOW I THINK THE
COLLABORATIVE RELATIONSHIP WE
HAVE WITH CAL FIRE IN THE THE
STRONG WORKING RELATIONSHIP OR
WHAT BASIS THE SUCCESS AND AGREE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THIS 19% IS TIED IN PERCENTAGE
OF LIKE RESOURCES FOR THIS STATE
MISSION THAT WE PROVIDE --
IT'S ALSO IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OPINION IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE TO
ESTABLISH THE FUNDING SOURCE
ITSELF SO AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND AND WE MAKE
OURSELVES AVAILABLE TO WORK WITH
STAFF AS NEEDED.
SO YOU YOU PREFER THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCES METHODOLOGY IS ON A
CONTINUING 19% FORMULA YES.
OKAY.
THANK YOU --
QUESTIONS.
AND THAT BRINGS US TO THE END OF
THIS -- WE
HAVE AT OUR VOTES RIGHT SO IT.
TO BRING THE SENATE TO THE END
OF THE FORMAL PART OF OUR
HEARING AND WE WILL.
CALL ON ABSENT MEMBERS TO COME
BACK AND AT ON THEIR VOTES THOSE
OF YOU WHO ARE HERE WHO HAVE AT
ARMS WILL DO THOSE RIGHT NOW
[inaudible]
AND ISSUE NUMBER THREE CURRENT
VOTE FOUR ZERO FONG.
WITH YOUR WALLET [inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
YEAH -- YEAH
OKAY YOU'RE RIGHT [inaudible]
YEAH THANKS.
THIS IS ME.
HELLO MY GAME.
ITEMS WE HEARD ISSUE NUMBER
THREE CURRENT VOTE FIVE ZERO
MULLIN.
ISSUE NUMBER SIX CURRENT VOTE
FIVE ZERO MULLIN.
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT CURRENT VOTE
FIVE ZERO MULLIN [inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
ISSUES FOR ALL RIGHT.
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR FIVE THE
CURRENT VOTE FIVE ZERO MULLIN.
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE FOR VOTE.
FIVE ZERO MULLIN.
GOOD LOOKING NOW.
WITH THE NOT YET MISS RADIUS
[inaudible]
X.
.
OUR MEETING IS ADJOURNED